good morning everybody it's morning it's
like a real job this is like a regular
like a regular job this episode of the
Joe Rogan experience is brought to you
by nature box nature box is a way that
you can get delicious healthy snacks
delivered to your home or your office I
haven't delivered to my house but
they're the official snack of the Joe
Rogan experience now official really
yummy stuff and you can get it as good
for you as you like meaning you know you
could order pretzels or if you want to
you can go gluten free low sugar they
have zero trans fats zero high-fructose
corn syrup
nothing artificial and they're great
they taste delicious there's there's a
ones that you guys will never see
there's shurochka
cashews they're not getting in here they
never make it they they get to my house
I open the box I pop it open I said
where the fucking cashews Oh
give me them bitches I never I'm never
bringing them in here I'll just tell you
right now Jamie never getting in them
sriracha cashews unless he sent like a
triple order they're too good my
favorite new snack but naturebox has
free shipping anywhere in the US and
it's just an awesome alternative to
vending machine snacks if you're at work
and you're looking for snacks all the
time and you hit that vending machine
like what can I eat here that doesn't
make me feel like a piece of shit
usually the answer is nothing you know
maybe you might go with potato chips
over candy bars or fucking cookies or
something stupid but you could you could
eat fairly clean I mean you could you
could get really clean where you could
have like they have these spicy
pistachios that are delicious or like I
said you can go with pretzels but I
recommend the sriracha cashews oh
they're so good they're so good dude
trust me it would be your favorite thing
if I ever bought it man
never make it in your son but naturebox
just allows you to eat eat healthy and
have it delivered to you
and cut out all the nonsense of that
that terrible feeling that you get when
you eat crappy food and just get angry
at yourself but they have South Pacific
plantain chips or another one fantastic
they're never making them in here they
just they get devoured but go to nature
box common hmm and say 50% off your
first box that's nature box.com Ford /
Rogan naturebox.com/tyler augen enjoy it
I enjoy it and like I said they're the
official snack food of the Joe Rogan
experience would you say and enjoy it
Brody Stephens enjoy it
we're also brought to you by audit comm
that is o n n IT audit is a human
optimization website we sell you the
tools that you can use to optimize your
health your life your fitness we sell
things like strength and conditioning
equipment like kettlebells and battle
ropes and mace balls and these all these
things that we use for steel maces all
these things that we use for strength
and conditioning workouts as well as
healthy foods like hemp horse protein
powder earth grown nutrients which is an
excellent supplement to your average
diet and the average healthy diet most
folks
the reality is you don't quite get
enough nutrients you don't quite get
enough healthy protein don't quite get
enough good foods and your in your diet
most of us are too busy most of us have
jobs most of us work well there's
there's certain ways that you can add to
your diet where you can give yourself
the building blocks give yourself the
tools that just the healthy nutrients
that your body needs like earth grown
nutrients and earth grown nutrients is
an awesome new supplement that we have
that's a combination of a bunch of
different things an antioxidant brant
blend that is all food based based on
things like Peruvian purple corn acai
fruit grape skin a ton of different
ingredients and it has a jaw-dropping 75
thousand or
SCOR the ORAC score is the antioxidant
score all that is explained on on it far
better than I'll be able to explain it
to you it also has a power green blend
with spirulina alfalfa oat grass kale
barley wheat grass all these different
things you can add it to a smoothie you
can add it to just a glass of water and
drink it and what it does is it gives
you a little cushioning it gives you
just sort of a nice supplement to cover
the distance between what most folks eat
and what really your body actually needs
and deserves
and what Anand is designed for and what
we're what what our goals are is to give
you everything that you need to optimize
your health and your fitness and just to
to sort of bridge the gap between what
the average person takes in in their
life and then has in their body and what
you really could actually use in need
and when it comes to the strength and
conditioning equipment we just buy the
best shit we can possibly find whether
it's AB wheels or medicine balls or
kettlebells we try to find the highest
quality stuff we try to find the stuff
that we find that is the most beneficial
for strength and fitness and then we
sell it to you the most reasonable
weight rates that we can if you use the
code word Rogan you will save 10% off
any and all supplements at on it that's
O
n n I t and use the code word Rogan all
right Randall Carlson is here it's early
in the morning why fuck around Jamie cue
the music
the Joe Rogan experience Joe Rogan
podcast by night
trying to get the old brain fired up in
the a.m. it's very unusual bit well I
usually get up around this time so do a
podcast around this time Randall Carlson
ladies and gentleman I first met Randall
quite a few years back in Atlanta he and
he blew my brain open with a bunch of
crazy talk about asteroids and just all
kinds of crazy shit sacred geometry and
you're a very interesting cat and you
you got a lot of cool stuff to talk
about so I'm glad we finally got you
here on the podcast you're a much
requested guest on my online forum so
folks know about you they know about
your work all these years of in on
anonymity and now I'm suddenly uh I
don't know if I'm ready for this job I
think you ready dude I feel it from you
it's this is your time to shine all
right Joe I'm coming from you that's all
all it requires well we had a great
conversation when we first met and we
did ever since then I've been trying to
figure out a way to repeat it online
there's videos of us actually having
parts of the conversation but it's
there's music in the background we're at
the comedy club and yeah so um you you
you first I don't remember what we first
started talking about but you blew my
mind when you started talking about the
Holocene crater and that this pretty
distinct evidence that you know there's
been more than one events on this earth
besides the one that everybody knows
about the 65 million year ago one where
the big chunk of rock hit the Yucatan
and killed the dinosaurs but there's
been a series of those and that these
things may very well be responsible for
a lot of the cataclysmic stories that
are in epic of gilgamesh the Noah's Ark
story all these different fables and
tales of ancient traditions maybe based
on these cataclysmic disasters and now
since we've spoken
science has started to validate a lot of
your theories and ideas even more
substantially the discovery
this nuclear glass that they find all
through a Europe and Asia tell me about
all this stuff well I did you catch the
thing about a month ago I think was into
New York Times most of the major
newspapers a group of former NASA
astronauts and scientists came out said
we were new evidence was showing it
we're probably somewhere between three
and ten times more likely to encounter
things than anybody had previously been
estimating even five to ten years ago it
was a pretty major article in most of
the mainstream media you mean by
encounter things by getting hit by
something yes of course you remember
what happened on February 15th of 2013
right what happened on February 15th was
that Russian yeah in what was really
interesting about that is because
everybody was at least people who are
interested in this sort of thing we're
kind of looking to the sky anyway
because this was the closest pass of an
asteroid coming within 17,000 miles of
the earth at the same time this object
totally out of the blue came in and
exploded over Chelyabinsk Siberia so it
was very interesting and coincidental if
there are such things as coincidences
that here when we're expecting this very
close flyby of an asteroid in your earth
asteroid coming actually within our
geosynchronous satellites within the
orbits of those satellites Wow at the
same time that this object is coming
within 17,000 miles of the earth
suddenly unexpectedly here comes the
second object and explodes with the
force of about a I believe it was about
a 50 kilo ton nuclear weapon and of
course it had exploded quite high about
20 I believe about 18 to 20 miles in the
atmosphere and so it didn't kill anybody
however the thing to bear in mind is if
that object had been just a little bit
bigger or it had been a little bit
denser or the angle of approach had been
a little steeper instead of 1,600
injuries that probably could have been
1600 or more casualties at that point I
think the world would have really sat up
and taken notice but
it was basically just a warning shot it
seems to me that our knowledge of
asteroids and meteors in packs and
things of that nature the art our actual
experience on it is based on this short
window that we call human history which
is for the earth such a brief tiny blink
of an eye it is although I like to point
out there you know when you say human
history we're talking you know 4,500 to
5,000 years ago generally I think most
historians of ancient history will
usually say that the emergence of keenya
form writing in the Middle East marks
the beginning of official recorded
history but you got to bear in mind that
we modern humans have been around a lot
longer than that right now the as far as
the hard evidence goes is which which is
what I like to refer to which means
skeletal remains skeletal remains of
humans that as far as we know are
basically no different than than modern
humans if you put flesh on them and
dress them up in modern clothes and they
walk down the street you wouldn't think
they were anything unusual
modern skeletal skeletal remains of
modern humans are now dating between a
hundred and fifty and a hundred and
eighty thousand years so when you think
about that you know compared to what we
actually have over our record of history
a record of history is one 20th 125th
one thirtieth of the actual time that we
humans have been here now now it could
be that modern humans have actually been
here much longer than than 180 thousand
years we have no way of knowing at what
point we moderns first appeared on this
planet but when you think of a hundred
and eighty thousand years compared to
let's say in round numbers five thousand
years it means that there's a lot of the
human story missing and the thing that's
always intrigued me is that given the
assumption that they would have had the
same intelligence as us the same big
they've got the same brain case size the
same cranial capacity so one would
assume that with brains as big as our
modern brain
they were able to think they had
forethought they were able to plan ahead
presumably have a you know have some
kind of a tradition that could be passed
on from generation to generation and
accumulated learning but what we see is
that there's basically no record to
speak of of what people were doing
culturally and and that has led a lot of
scientists to assume that for all those
tens of thousands of years and hundreds
and hundreds of generations that people
were essentially living nothing more
than a subsistence kind of
hunter-gatherer existence right but what
they haven't taken into account is the
extremity of some of the global changes
that have occurred in in the interval
that we humans have been here and as we
go through our discussion today and I'll
we'll pull up some images I think you'll
begin to get an idea of how extreme and
how sweeping some of these changes have
been and why in the aftermath of those
changes we wouldn't shouldn't expect to
find a whole lot of hard at cultural
evidence because what you'll hopefully
begin to appreciate is that were some of
these events of the scale and magnitude
that have happened probably a dozen or
more times in the hundred and fifty or
two hundred thousand years that we've
been here were those events to occur
today ten thousand years from now
archaeologists would be sifting through
the through the rubble looking for any
kind of evidence that we had ever been
here and that's the thing we have to get
into our consciousness you know I guess
if there's any any implication to the
work that I've been doing is that we
certainly can't take our present
position for granted it seems very
difficult for us to put into perspective
numbers like ten thousand or a hundred
thousand or a million we know that the
universe has been around allegedly for
fourteen billion yes so the earth is 4.6
billion those numbers are so weird to it
they don't register they're just like I
know four billion is more than
400,000 but both of them are alien you
know what I mean it's like huh I don't
think we could really wrap our head
around the idea that 10,000 years is
such an incredible length of time that
if you left a car out for 10,000 years
within you know three or four thousand
it would be absorbed completely by the
earth Joe within three or four centuries
really oh yeah I mean if you look at I
mean steel body cars I remember very
well as a kid not far from where we
lived there was a auto junk auto
graveyard and all the teenagers around
there who were racing cars back in the
50s and crashing them up and everything
they seemed to end up there and as a kid
I used to like to go and kind of hang
around there and play in some of the old
cars but they were already after sitting
out there for ten years I mean already
well underway - rusting away I mean once
that process of oxidation begins to take
place it accelerates mm-hmm not far from
where I live in Atlanta there was an old
iron bridge that had been built around
the 1890s and it's no longer there but
by the eighteen by the 1980s it had
almost rusted to nothing
and within a century it almost rusted to
nothing yeah metal does not last long
when exposed to the elements there was
an interesting series of shows a few
years ago I think was it had to do with
the idea of if what if humans just
suddenly departed and what if we took
humans out of the equation what would
happen to all of the infrastructure left
behind just under normal kind of gradual
istic change that we're used to within
you know the last few centuries the
upshot of it was is the 10,000 years
from now it's pretty much gone you know
I mean if you look at the the the great
buildings that make up all the
metropolis metropolitan areas now of the
world most of them are steel frame
structures and they're you know clothed
in in a skin that that will keep the
elements out maybe for a half a century
but without maintenance I mean you know
that the the Golden Gate Bridge up in
San Francisco is constantly ongoing
undergoing maintenance because if you
stop maintaining it the media
it starts decaying immediately it starts
rusting and interesting if you think
about if if we suddenly if humans left
the planet ten thousand years from now
you know some some interstellar
anthropologists arrived
what would they see that would indicate
that we had been here what do you think
would still be left after ten thousand
years there's actually two things that
they named in this particular program I
bet you can guess one of them out
Rushmore
Mount Rushmore good good guess yes
that's one of them and of course the
Great Pyramid right the other one and
that's it you know everything else is
gone Wow
now when you when you now begin to
factor in the thing that I've been
basically working with is the idea that
we have these intermittent I call them
nonlinearities discontinuities within
the normal orderly progression of things
the catastrophes if you will superimpose
a few of those in the process and
basically five thousand ten thousand
years from now you're not going to find
much to show that we had been here
that's incredible
and when you see structures like gobekli
tepe
which is within the last couple decades
been on earth in in Turkey which is
really thrown giant monkey wrench into
the timeline of the hunter-gatherer
transition into the modern agricultural
city we're we're in a weird state
because people are starting to dig up
these things and gobekli tepe was a
completely unknown structure until this
one farmer or herder had found a stone
and started unearthing it and then
realized it was these huge stone pillars
of an unknown civilization carved with
three-dimensional shapes of these
animals some of them were aren't even
native to the area so it's incredibly
confusing and purposely covered up 14 to
twelve to fourteen thousand years ago
which means that who knows how long it
was there before it could have been
several thousand years old when they
decided to cover it up but it was
purposely filled in an enormous area
purposely filled in somewhere around
twelve thousand years
could it have been purposely covered up
in order to protect it and preserve it
could be right that we were hoping what
they were hoping rather that someone
like us would come along not honestly
definitely not me
maybe you but we come along and uncover
it and then go whoa what's what's this
all about like maybe they knew that
there were going to be moments in time
where these things happen these impacts
these asteroid impacts and that there
needed to be some sort of a way of
keeping track or some sort of a way of
preserving well that that would probably
be one way of preserving it for sure and
the other thing would be is just like
you mentioned you mentioned we the two
things Mount Rushmore and the Great
Pyramid of course are both built of
stone which is obviously much more
durable than steel or you know the
fabricated materials that we're making
today even plastics even plastics are
going to degrade over a few millennium
but if you want to preserve something
for millennia make it out of stone and
make it monumental and you know we're
looking at it's something like you just
made an interesting point about it could
have how much pre vyas to the to the
burial had it actually been there and
you know it's difficult to date stone
the way you would dates known is you
know you can use various some Oh Cosmo
genic ways where when you expose stone
to atmosphere it's going to accumulate
cosmic rays which cause changes within
the stone that can actually be measured
but if it's buried it's not going to be
subject to cosmic rays so that you can't
date it that way which you'd probably
have to do is date find some organic
material within the soil matrix or
matrix of material around it and date
that material but even there see that's
not going to tell that's only going to
give you a minimum date so in other
words the structure is there for who
knows how long they decide to bury it
and they bring in the material and bury
it and if some organic material is in
that soil it's not necessarily going to
be indicative of the age of the stone
structure itself it's going to be
indicative of the time at which it was
buried
and how did they determine that it was
buried at 12,000 years ago was it the
uniformity of the depth of I would
assume now I I haven't made a study of
gobekli tepe yet I'm hoping that when I
get a chance to hang out with Graham
Hancock I'm gonna get filled in on all
the details of that mm I don't know
specifically about that other you know
Manya I do suspect that you know ganang
Padang is probably very old it's in
Indonesia a lot of the monumental
stonework that we find like it bailed
back where you have these monstrous
megaliths probably go back to
Pleistocene times and when I say
Pleistocene I'm talking about the period
from like ten thousand years back to
about two and a half million years ago
the time during which there has been
this succession of glacial ages and
interglacial ages hmm and you know you
mentioned the term Holocene we talked
about that Holocene is essentially the
modern geological epoch we've been in
this policy
epoch for generally they say ten
thousand years in rough numbers although
it's becoming much more precisely dated
now you'll find a lot of references in
the scientific literature that says
gives the date eleven point six or
eleven thousand six hundred years as
being the onset of the Holocene which is
an interesting date for me because I
know if you have ever read Plato and his
accounts of Atlantis there's two of his
dialogues courteous and Timaeus in which
he describes Atlantis and he gives the
dating in there at least on three
separate occasions and he always places
that you know there's this whole success
the whole lineage of the story goes back
to soul on who was a historical
character an authenticated historical
character who lived at about 600 BC and
he was a lawgiver and poet in Athens and
due to political pressures and stuff he
went into a 10-year exile and during
that ten-year exile he went to Egypt and
it was there that he presumably would
heard the tale of Atlantis from elderly
Egyptian priests and he was told and
came back and then told the story to his
grants
who told it again to to several
individuals before it actually got to
Socrates and then Plato who presumably
wrote it down but what it's interesting
is that in in Plato's account he gives
the dating for the demise of Atlantis as
9,000 years prior to so longe exile to
Egypt well given that that took place in
give or take a decade or two 600 BC we
go back that's 2600 years ago okay add
that to the 9,000 years and we've got
eleven thousand six hundred years ago
now according to Plato's account he says
that it was shortly after this great war
between the Atlanteans and the proto
Athenians that there was this tremendous
cataclysm and Atlantis sunk beneath the
waves so he's giving that date at eleven
thousand six hundred years ago we now
know from the scientific record that at
eleven thousand six hundred years ago
there was a major climate transition and
there was a catastrophic warming spike
that was associated with a mega scale
meltdown event of the great ice sheets
that were covering North America it was
this event at eleven thousand six
hundred essentially jerked the planet
out of the the depths of this Ice Age
that it had been in for thousands and
thousands of years with that melting you
had a rapid rise of sea level so it's
very interesting that the date that he
gives is precisely now the date that
that the scientists are giving for this
transition from what's called the
Younger Dryas I think Graham has
mentioned that in in some of your
interviews with him that the younger
driest which was this climate spasm that
ended the last ice age so if we look at
the chronology of events around 26,000
years ago we were in the latter phases
of a what appears to have been an
interglacial period not too much
different from what we're in now around
26,000 years ago the climate rapidly
degenerated
and these massive glaciers had expanded
during this what they called the final
phase or the late Wisconsin they refer
to it because initially they were
looking for this evidence in the state
of Wisconsin so they they named that
this last final phase the latest onsen
so around 26,000 years ago we see the
the launching of this final phase of the
Ice Age the late was concen then at
around 13,000 years ago as the dates are
now giving it there was this enormous
spasm of warming and this seemed to be
associated with rapid melting and the
first real rapid sea level rise okay
what happened is after a very short
interval of time the climate snapped
back into the full depths of glacial
cold now what had happened was
if you go back 18,000 years ago this was
the coldest part of the ice age I mean
this was bitterly cold period of time
where I live in in Georgia was the
forests that grew there were like the
forests you find in Canada
now you had tundra up in Northern
Kentucky in southern Idaho tundra in
southern southern Ohio excuse me so it
was a really really different climate
and once you got to northern Ohio in the
northern United States where New York
City is Chicago the Great Lakes the
Dakotas all of that was under this
massive ice sheet thousands of feet
thick when you go up into Canada over
Canada the ice sheet was up to two miles
thick I mean think about that two miles
thick of ice and it reached from the
Atlantic to the Pacific Ocean and from
the northern United States as far south
as the 45th parallel all the way up to
the Arctic Circle now that is a
drastically different world
bear in mind to that with that much ice
piled up on the surface of the land sea
levels which contributed the water that
formed that ice had to go down and it's
now well-documented that sea levels
during the depth of the ice age were at
least 400 feet lower than now which
which means that the continental shelves
of the planet were basic
we exposed now where I live in Georgia
if you go out and stand right now on the
beach like a Cumberland Island which is
beautiful wilderness preserve you stand
there on the beach if you were suddenly
transported back to the depths of the
Ice Age you'd be in the middle of a
boreal forest meaning a northern forest
with spruce trees large trees alder
trees the kind of trees you find now in
the northern United States Canada of
that area and the beach wouldn't have
been anywhere anywhere close it would've
been another fifty seventy five hundred
miles further to the east because as the
sea level drops what happens it recedes
right and so when this final phase of
the Ice Age came on sea levels begin to
drop and so what it did was it exposed
all of these shallow marine ecology that
that rimmed all of the continents to the
atmosphere and basically would have
caused enormous ecological havoc
well then within a millennia or so the
forests had had expanded and had now
grown out so now off the eastern
seaboard of the United States they
constantly will find the remains of tree
stumps and forests that had been growing
there fourteen fifteen sixteen thousand
years ago now the ice begins to melt sea
level begins to rise now it's important
to realize that if we look at the way
modern civilization has evolved what do
we see is where did the first city show
up don't aren't they mostly trading
cities that show up their port cities
they show up along the confluence of
rivers they show up where rivers meet
the oceans they show up on on the
coastlines okay so if you had major
cities during the Ice Age and as Graham
has pointed out there are now four
hundred feet underwater Wow so you begin
to appreciate when you begin to really
look at the history of our planet what
you realize is that it's been just
almost unimaginably dynamic this an
alteration from a from a interglacial to
a glacial age is an extreme process and
so I guess the upshot of it is is that
you know when we look now at the the
climate record that we have in hand now
which has been
pretty much reconstructed with a fair
amount of accuracy back to about 400,000
years and these are primarily based on
ice cores extracted from Greenland
extracted from Antarctica extracted from
mountain glaciers and and most mostly
mostly Antarctic and Greenland know when
you pull out that ice core it's layered
you think think of cutting down a tree
and looking at the annual layers where
you can actually count the number of
layers in a in a cross section of a tree
log and you'll know how old it is right
well it's very similar in in an ice core
you've got layers annual layers because
each year there's snow that falls it
gets compressed into fern f ir n which
is the transitional phase between snow
and glacial ice and it eventually gets
compressed into glacial ice and when you
look at a cross-section of the ice core
you'll see these fine layers in there
right so they can go back and they can
look at these layers they can count the
layers and there's a lot of things going
on in these layers oxygen isotopes are a
critical one for ascertaining climate
changes because oxygen isotopes are a
function of temperature and we have a
graph here we'll pull up in a minute we
can actually look at that but what we
see is that the climate is constantly
isolated back and forth and when we look
at the Holocene going back 10,000 years
and then we take that comparatively and
we go back 250 to 400 thousand years we
can now begin to reconstruct these
intervals of glacial periods
interglacial and here's the thing that
should be sobering to everybody on the
planet today as we think about climate
change and all of this because obviously
it's constantly in the news and all the
longest interglacial period now on
record for at least the last quarter
million years the longest one the
longest unbroken period of interglacial
warmth is the Holocene the one we're in
now we've already exceeded by several
millennia the longest previous period of
interglacial warmth I don't hear them
talking about that I don't hear al gore
talking about that I don't hear
anybody talking about that in mainstream
media but it's hard scientific fact yeah
we would be shitting our pants way more
if it was a global cooling than if it
was a global warming let me tell Rhonda
we're gonna pull up another graph we'll
pull up a graph in a minute which shows
you that even within the last couple of
thousand years periods of global cooling
have not been pleasant times periods of
global warming is when we see human
population expanding when we see
cultural advancement when we see
lifespans increasing when we see infant
mortality decreasing periods of global
cooling are when we see populations
going into decline when we see lifespans
diminishing you know we had a period of
global cooling that began between 536
and 540 ad it was this period of global
cooling that launched what we know of
the dark ages and this has now been well
documented by dendrochronologist Mike
Bailey is one of the the leaders of this
who's been looking at the climate
changes of the last couple thousand
years as preserved in the tree-ring
record between 536 in about 544 ad we
find that forest growth in the northern
hemisphere almost came to a stop and one
of the consequences of that was this it
was associated with a global cooling and
for multiple years running there were
agricultural collapses where because of
the cold and the damp that came on with
this you know the historical record it's
interesting because you read some of
these accounts that were preserved from
that period they talk about weeks at a
time where they couldn't see the Sun
they talk about when it did show up it
was just a feeble imitation of itself
they talk about you know years with no
summer basically so what you had was
succession of crop failures that led to
people becoming malnourished once they
became malnourished their immune systems
became weakened and in 542 ad about six
years after this well
documented transition occurred we had
the onset to the Justinian plague which
wiped out 1/3 the population of Europe
and it took 300 years to recover from
that and it didn't we didn't recover
from it until the climate shifted again
and we went into what's known as the
Medieval Warm Period and the Medieval
Warm Period was the time when the
Scandinavians were farming on the west
coast of Greenland were now it's
perennial e frozen and for about the
next couple of hundred years the climate
was according to some researchers and
some scientists as much as two degrees
warmer than now and you think it had to
have been warmer if if they were farming
in Greenland where it is now frozen
ground it had to have been warmer and
one of the things that happened with was
with this warming you had an expansion
of the the growing season and you also
had the the latitude belt at which
viable farming agriculture could be
practice shifted three to four hundred
miles north of where it had been which
meant that for the first time England
actually had a flourishing wine industry
which didn't exist previously and it has
only existed until recent times because
of genetically modified crops is now
allowing them to grow grapes where they
haven't been able to grow wine grapes
until we go back to the Medieval Warm
Period so what happened was now there
was a lot of food for people to eat
right people got healthier human
population began to increase right we've
been to accumulate wealth we begin to to
carry on commerce and trade after this
300 years of dark ages we're learning
receded into the into the monasteries
and life was very unpleasant very short
very brutal very unpleasant now we had
this warming period okay with the growth
with the expansion of agriculture and
the abundant food supply and the the
prolific harvests people were getting
strong healthy again statured and it's
been well documented that during this
two or three hundred years of the
medieval warming period humans
stature actually increased by inches
average human size okay
by 1150 this accumulated wealth that had
ensued from the the benign climate of
the Medieval Warm Period is what allowed
the the great Cathedral building era to
ensue which began between 11:30 and 1150
ad and what we see is these magnificent
cathedrals have you been to Europe and
visit in any other cthey put that on
your to-do list yeah get there and look
at some of these extraordinary works of
art that were built during the high
gothic or high middle ages between like
I said about 1150 and the early 1300s
they built 80 about 80 of these gigantic
magnificent cathedrals that required the
the organizing of thousands of highly
highly skilled craftsmen armies of
workers and craftsmen um you had
stonemasons and carpenters and glaciers
and astronomers and geometrician Xand
and all of these people brought together
to create these incredible cathedrals
and it was made possible by the fact
that European society had become
relatively wealthy and this wealth was
brought on by this global warmth right
now what we see go ahead to the to the
beginning to the end of this magnificent
Gothic building boom and and by the way
there's about 500 smaller Abbey's that
were constructed during this interval
this was a very prolific time for a
number of reasons this was the time that
you had the Templar knights forming
you've probably heard of that the
Templar knights I'm sure you had schools
of Kabbalah being founded in Spain and
and you had the rise of Cather ISM you
had the troubadours you had these
amazing spiritual things going on
amazing culturally it was a very
extraordinary time those high Middle
Ages well a lot of those Gothic
cathedrals were never finished and what
we see is that
some of them have the appearance you
know I'm a builder by profession and you
know it's it's I've looked at some of
these and but it's very much like as
they're going along building and then
all of a sudden one day nobody shows up
to work and there's still tools laying
around there's still materials that are
often a pile that we're waiting to be
incorporated into the structure and what
happened was that the climate began to
cool again between 13 15 and 13 20% of
this tremendous Gothic building boom is
when the climate began to cool and it
cool for the next several decades and
what we then see as a repeat of what
happened between 536 and 542 ad
agricultural collapses crops rotting in
the fields people going hungry between I
think was around between 1340 and 1345
the onset of the Black Plague and once
again the population of Europe was
decimated and it took a hundred and
fifty years basically to recover from
that and what we see is that what what
what was happening is the planet was
shifting into what's called the Little
Ice Age well you've probably heard that
term the Little Ice Age right there was
two phases to the Little Ice Age and the
first phase began like I said around
1320 lat said about a hundred and fifty
years and then there was a break and it
was during that break that warm period
that basically the Renaissance kicked in
and we began to really move forward the
second phase of the Little Ice Age came
in during the 1600s and it was actually
even colder than the first phase and
worldwide glaciers expanded to the
largest they had been in 10,000 to
12,000 years since the end of the big
Ice Age throughout the whole Holocene
glaciers had been smaller now during the
big ice the Little Ice Age they grew and
they grew to the biggest that they've
been in 10,000 years it's important to
have that context of understanding when
we talk about glacier recession because
the glaciers begin to recede around the
middle of the 19th century worldwide as
the Little Ice Age begin to wane and
glow
warmth warmth begin to return to the
planet this happened in the mid 1800s
around 1840 to 1860 we see the Little
Ice Age coming to an end and at that
point the glaciers worldwide began to
recede they began to contract they've
been pretty much contracting uniformly
since then so when we're talking about
glacier recession it's important to
understand that the glacier recession
really began a century and a half ago or
more and has basically consider
continued more or less uniformly since
then with no real change with the advent
of human fossil fuel to the atmosphere
human carbon dioxide which began really
in earnest during the Second World War
is when when we begin to add significant
amounts of carbon dioxide to the
atmosphere it's important to realize
that the glaciers had been receding
almost a full century before that point
so when you see all this modern hysteria
about global warming and the human
created global warming that we keep
hearing about in the news and that our
influence on the atmosphere does it
drive you crazy I mean do you think it's
silly we obviously human beings are
contributing to the carbon footprint
right obviously obviously yes and
obviously that has an effect on global
warming yes yes but you gotta bear in
mind the carbon dioxide it's only one
variable in a very complex equation
right there are many factors influencing
climate of which carbon dioxide is only
one my problem with so much of the the
stuff that's coming out in mainstream
media which is coming through the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change is simply that when when they
were instituted back in the early 90s by
the United Nations the United Nations
Framework Convention on Climate Change
basically gave them a mandate which is
demonstrate that humans are causing
climate change right so they focused
exclusively on carbon dioxide but
there's all kinds of other things going
on
for example cosmic rays are constantly
bombarding
the earth right cosmic rays produce
clouds the more of the cosmic rays
penetrate the atmosphere the more low
altitude cloud cover there is low
altitude clouds reflect heat back into
space now the amount of cosmic rays
penetrating the atmosphere is a function
of a couple of things you've got the
heliosphere which is the whole
essentially the the the the energy
envelope of the Sun which encompasses
the whole solar system the Sun actually
is fairly variable and what that means
is that when the solar wind is in more
intense phase like when when the
sunspots for example are very active the
solar wind is is much stronger what that
does is it serves as a buffer that
prevents cosmic rays from penetrating
the atmosphere of the earth as as
strongly as they did previously also the
geomagnetic field of the earth acts as a
buffer so here's two things that are
completely not included in the scenarios
of the IPCC but probably have a very
profound effect on global climate the
Earth's geomagnetic field is you know
probably know that the geomagnetic field
has periodically throughout Earth
history disappeared completely sometimes
it's it's disappeared and come back with
reverse polarity
well that geomagnetic field acts as a
buffer which helps to reduce the amount
of cosmic rays penetrating the
atmosphere as it disappeared completely
I don't know and I don't know if really
anybody knows I haven't kept up with all
of the most recent research what's
geomagnetism but you know when you've
gotten you hold a little compass in your
hand and it points to North right right
okay that's the geomagnetic field that's
being measured by the compass it's
moving it's fluctuating and for whatever
reason throughout the history of the
earth it has completely disappeared at
some points and his reverse polarity
it's it was the the reversing of the
polarity of the geomagnetic field that
helped
prove the reality of continental drift
because as the the mid-atlantic ridge
separates and and and lava flows out it
crystallizes and locked into the
crystalline structure of the of the lava
is the direction of the magnetic field
and the polarity of the magnetic field
is imprinted in there if you look at the
research going back to the 1950s they
realized that you had stripes affect
effectively as you moved away from the
mid-atlantic ridge as the as the lava
flowed out and crystallized locked in
the geomagnetic field they looked at it
and they could see that there were times
when it had completely reversed itself
and so this was like very powerful
evidence that the theory of continental
drift was right that the Atlantic Ocean
had been spreading and in getting back
to this whole atlantis thing which is
interesting to me is because when you
look at at REE Plato's account he
describes Atlantis as being west of the
pillars of Herakles which of course is
the Straits of Gibraltar the mouth of
the Mediterranean he describes how if
you go you come to some islands then you
come to some more islands and that was
the the island complex of Atlantis and
beyond that was another cold continent
he describes that right if you look in
the middle of the Atlantic Ocean you've
got the Azores Plateau which is now a
couple of thousand feet under the sea
the Azore islands are the tops of
mountains that that emerge from the
surface of the ocean right and they sit
right on the Atlantic the mid-atlantic
ridge now the mid-atlantic ridge some of
the thinnest crusts on the planet right
and it's it's like a giant suture or a
giant crack that runs up halfway around
the planet well when you have an ice age
and you start piling ice up onto like
the North American continent what
happens is the weight of that ice begins
to crush the the crust of the earth down
in
to the mantel it's called isostasy which
is a vertical movement you know
continental drift is horizontal isostasy
is vertical now it's just like right now
you're sitting on that soft chair right
and your ass is creating a depression in
the cushion of the chair right that's
isostatic depression you didn't realize
that did you know that your ass is
creating isostatic depression right and
when you get up and you walk away then
you will have isostatic compensation
you'll have isostatic rebound because
the cushion will now rise because the
weight has been removed it's the same
thing with the ice mass on the continent
the ice mass was hundreds of billions of
trillions of tons of ice it pressed the
center of the North American continent
or the center of at least Canada down
perhaps as much as several thousand feet
into the mantle with the removal of that
ice the land begins to rebound Hudson
Bay is the depression left over from the
thickest part of the ice right now our
photographs we could probably even pull
some up here in a minute there are
photographs taken where you can see the
elevated shoreline surrounding Hudson
Bay because it's still rising right
what's interesting too is if you look at
the the the distance between these
shorelines you'll see that early on
there's a greater distance because the
land was rising faster as the millennia
have have gone on the distance
separating each shoreline has diminished
but now you have to think that all of
that weight is being transferred back
into the ocean basins a lot of it was
dumped directly into the Atlantic Ocean
either via like the st. Lawrence River
up there the Hudson River up in the New
York area or via the Mississippi River
into the Gulf of Mexico now you've got
all this water dumping back into the
ocean like I said ocean levels are
coming up hundreds of feet right so now
you're adding all of this weight to the
ocean basin and now you've got the
mid-atlantic ridge which is some of the
thinnest crust on the earth right this
is what it's doing it's like a hinge
line
right so now you picture during a
glacial age when the weight is taken out
it does this lifts up lifts up listening
not watching yeah when the ice melts the
water goes in sea level rises it
subsides right now you look at the
Azores Plateau is a chunk of the African
plate that got left over when the
continents separated around 70 to 80
million years ago right if we you've
seen the maps in the showing how you can
fit the contents together yeah if you
fit these back together if you if you
reverse continental drift go back about
70 or 80 million years and it's all fits
together like a piece of the puzzle but
when it's separated a piece of the of
the African plate got left behind and
this is what is the Azores Plateau and
it sits right there astride the
mid-atlantic ridge it's maybe a little
bit smaller than the Maya then Iceland
which is considered to be an island but
of a pretty good sized island right now
if you're doing this and you have as
much as two or three thousand feet or
maybe more of this vertical movement
right and you add to that to four
hundred feet of sea level rise
now you can I think begin to get a
scientific rationale for how you may
have had a large island in the
mid-atlantic back during the Ice Age
also additional evidence have suggested
that the Gulf Stream which now basically
brings subtropical warmth up to
northwestern Europe I mean if you were
to terminate the Gulf Stream England
would would have some pretty pretty
malignant times so in northwestern
Europe because the warmth is being
brought up by that Gulf Stream right
well during the Ice Age of the Gulf
Stream diverted to the south at about 45
to 46 degrees which was hundreds of
miles farther south than it now goes so
essentially if you look at the Azores
plateau a big chunk of that Azores
Plateau would have been above sea level
during the Ice Age and that Gulf Stream
with its warmth would have just
basically embraced at sea
if you suddenly Joe found yourself
transported mysteriously back to the Ice
Age that's probably where you might want
to go is the Azores Plateau it might
have been of one of the most benign
places on earth to live during the Ice
Age and if there was a place where
civilization could evolve that would be
a very logical place for it to occur
there's nothing really pseudo-scientific
now about assuming that there could have
been some type of historic reality
behind these stories of Atlantis of
course the problem is is the woowoo
factor that has gotten so grafted on to
these stories but you know crystals and
aliens and flying ships and I mean we
don't know but you know we don't have
any hard evidence but the hard evidence
does suggest that there could have been
some very benign habitable islands large
islands in the Mid Atlantic during the
Ice Age wow so that's intense that's so
incredible it so it's it's it's so crazy
to think how how much things have
changed while human beings have been
here the idea that during gobekli tepe
which is 12,000 years ago that north
america was covered with ice and they
this was when these people in Turkey had
created this incredible structure so
when you see this the the modern
hysteria about global warming which has
really essentially been like a wrestling
match between the left and the right
it's this weird thing where the right
wants to support like burning coal and
they don't want to diminish the economy
by putting all these environmental
regulations on Natural Resources and
then the the left which is screaming at
the top of their lungs that the sky is
following the oceans are gonna rise and
people are gonna drown when you when you
know so much about what has happened
over the course of the earth when you've
studied this for a great deal of time
like you have what is your take on all
this stuff well I guess my take is is is
fairly simple I I tend to think that you
know if you know if you look at the the
the whole process of if you look at the
carbon cycle for example
what what you see there is interesting
we have to I can talk to this into this
as much as possible yeah have as little
variation in the tone as possible thank
you you know putting this into context
we have to say right now we're
approaching 400 parts per million of the
ambient amount of co2 in the atmosphere
at the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution it was about a hundred parts
per million less it's you could say
basically that over the last century we
have increased the amount of co2
measurable co2 into the atmosphere
assuming that it's all from us now I
mean there's questions about that too
because if there are other factors
inducing global warming such as changes
in solar irradiance the amount of
insulation penetrating the atmosphere
and so on it means that the oceans are
warming as a result of that okay
oceans are a gigantic carbon dioxide
sink when they're warm they exude carbon
dioxide when they're cold they absorb it
right so if you have a natural warming
it's going to expel some carbon dioxide
so it's not even clear necessarily that
that 100 parts per million is totally
the result of fossil fuel burning but
for the sake of argument let's say that
it is okay a hundred parts per million
that's minuscule trace of this very
important constituents of our atmosphere
you know that carbon dioxide is what
fuels photosynthesis right and if you
start reducing the amount of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere and you start
once you start dropping below 200 parts
per million and you get down to about
150 to 100 photosynthesis plant food of
synthesis starts shutting down I mean
it's kind of like the amount of co2 in
the atmosphere right now is at the very
bottom of the scale you know if we look
at history going back when you mentioned
the cretaceous-tertiary when the
dinosaurs ruled there have been many
times more the the amount of co2 up to
well in excess of a thousand parts per
million
several thousand parts per million in
the atmosphere but if we have increased
the amount of co2 by 100 parts per
million
in a hundred years it means we've for
every million molecules of air up there
we add one molecule of co2 every year or
two maybe try to make it a little bit
more comprehensible if for every hundred
thousand molecules of air up there every
10 years we add one molecule of co2 I'm
not convinced that that's going to lead
to global catastrophe
I mean think of it this way you got a
huge tank with a hundred thousand fish
in it every 10 years you're throwing one
more fish are you even going to notice
that you know I think that what's
happened is that co2 like I said is one
variable in a very complex equation but
all of the other variables as far as the
the government-funded research goes have
been excluded from the debate and what
does Bayes me is that we're told that
all scientists agree on this no all
scientists don't agree when you have
though a major government funded program
like climate change research which is
funded to the tune of about two billion
dollars per year you're gonna have a
large vested interest in basically I
mean if these guys came out and said nah
co2 is really not a big deal it's
perhaps fueling plant growth and this is
an interesting aside you know if you
look at the the projections of forests
and inventory back in the 50s and 60s
based upon deforestation as a result of
timber as a result of agriculture the
projections that at how quickly forest
inventories were going to rebound if you
look at those projections back in the
50s and 60s and then you realize that in
the ensuing period of time we've now got
exhaustive highly accurate satellite
surveys that can actually count the
number of hectares of forests what's
interesting is in the 90s when they
really started looking at this date of
just how much forest there was compared
to what the
Texans were there was like 25 to 40%
more forests worldwide than anybody had
predicted what fueled this prolific
forest growth well it's very likely that
at least part of it was because of the
slight increase in co2 there's a result
as a result of our fossil fuel burning
now we put in every year we burn about
introduced into the atmosphere about 6
billion tons of co2 well there's about
750 or 760 billion tons of co2 in the
atmosphere naturally and at least a
third of that is cycling through from
from atmosphere into the biosphere into
the oceans and so on so our contribution
isn't really that significant but
another part of the the argument is that
and this has been admitted right in the
IPCC reports is that based on the amount
of fossil fuel that we're burning there
should be twice as much co2 into the
atmosphere in the atmosphere as we're
now measuring so what they have been
talking about for about 15 years now is
where is the missing carbon what's this
missing carbon sink well probably some
of what's going into the ocean but most
likely a lot of it is going into fueling
plant growth and forest growth worldwide
and there's a lot of studies that are
beginning to come out now that shows
that perhaps some of the desert areas of
the planet rather than expanding are
actually contracting so you know at this
point there's a lot of things we still
have to learn when it comes down to
understanding the climate we're in the
infancy you you can't talk to a single
climatologist and come up with a one
single coherent answer or agreement on
what has actually provoked the planet to
go into a full ice age or what has
caused it to come out of an ice age if
you don't have if you don't know that we
still have a hell of a lot to learn
about how the climate works so I get
really frustrated when I hear this claim
that the debate is over the debate is
over because the debate hasn't really
even begun yet
you see we need to really look at all of
these other factors as well I mean when
you look at wind currents and ocean
currents you have the the El Nino
Southern Oscillation you have the the
the Indian Ocean dipole you have the
Pacific decadal oscillation all of these
things have a very profound influence on
the climate but they're essentially
being ignored within the within the
government funded science to a large
extent and you have a lot of scientists
who have objected to some of the claims
of certainty made by the IPCC scientists
and for the most part the left likes to
demonize them this is people like oh I
think probably the the leading demon of
climate deniers is Fred singer because
he once was given an a ten thousand
dollar unsolicited donation from Exxon
years and years ago but you've got guys
like Roy Spencer and Craig and Sherwood
did so and Robert balling and Timothy
ball and and and the list goes on and on
these are distinguished climate
scientists that have devoted their lives
to understanding climate science who say
well there's a lot of flaws in the
methodology of the IPCC but by saying
that now they have entered the the spawn
of hell hmm according to the left now in
your right see what happened it's turned
into a political football
it's an idol on ideological debate it's
an ideological debate a political debate
and it's just too bad that the science
of the thing has into suffering the
consequence it is it is fascinating
because even hearing you say this I'm
thinking like it starts popping triggers
like I'm not the type of person that
worries too much about being labeled
because I've been labeled a million
times already as an idiot it does it
doesn't bother me to start contemplating
the possibilities of controversial ideas
but when I'm listening to you saying
this all I'm hearing is the knee-jerk
reaction of climate denier climate to
always a climate denier this guy's a
climate denier and seeing these fucking
things that we've
grown to be accustomed to on television
where you have a guy on the left who has
one point of view and a guy on the right
who says something wacky and then
everybody fights about it and you know
and then the YouTube clips you look at
the comments and it's filled with this
guy's a faggot and that guy's this this
guy eat shit I hope your house goes
underwater you fucking climate denied it
says and when I'm listening to you and I
mean this podcast has been over an hour
already and it's incredibly complex we
have barely scratched the surface and
you're never going to hear anything like
this on any television show because most
people feel that the general public does
not have the attention span to absorb
all of this information is really
complex explanation of the known science
of the changing of the atmosphere of the
earth so when people start talking about
climate denying and you know what what
is going on with climate change what
they're really doing is establishing
their position on what side I am the
side of I'm a rational person who
believes in science and education but
how much of this have you actually
explored how much of it has anybody
actually looked at well I'm a person who
supports industry and I'm a person who
believes the United States needs to
recover from our economic disaster and
you know if we got a frack a few wells
you know so be it you know there's these
two very distinct and oftentimes shallow
ideological perspectives and when I say
shallow I mean shallow from the point of
the general public person like me who's
not a scientist observing it and just
picking aside with very little
information really and you talk to I
would like to grab the average person
the average lefty and the average righty
that thinks that they're you know they
have an opinion on global change and
just just do me a favor and just write
down what you know just write down I
don't want you looking online do you
have an opinion write down what you know
do you know dogshit
most people know dogshit it's true it's
true Joe it's so fascinating it's so
fascinating to me because it becomes
another one of those things ideology is
that I mean I I don't remember who said
it but it's it's the enemy of free
thinking mm-hmm you you get in these
ideological clusters and then anything
outside of this thing these
predetermined patterns of behavior that
you've to subscribe to anything becomes
forbidden it becomes you can't even
entertain it you can't even approach the
idea you see it with everything you see
with atheism you see it with you see it
with any isms with feminism with the
men's rights you see it with with people
who subscribe to the right people
subscribe to the left any variables that
don't fit into their equation that
they've already subscribed to they don't
want to be labeled as that other side
and any time they don't want to be
labeled they start ignoring any evidence
or any ideas that don't fit within this
really rigid description that's exactly
right
I mean that is you hit the nail on the
head just weird exactly right people
where people get locked into these
ideological paradigms and then from that
point on basically their perspective is
modified more by emotion and rationality
more by you know their feelings rather
than real information and and it's too
bad I mean I know what to blame it on
maybe the fact that the government runs
all the schools I don't know you know
the government monopolizes the education
system so they're not teaching people
critical thinking skills they're not
teaching people how to actually become
how to be scientifically literate which
is really sad but you know we it's it's
like you know you you keep hearing the
term climate change denier right well
there's no such thing I don't think
you're gonna find a single climate
scientist of any persuasion that denies
that the climate is changing and you got
to realize that the the terminology has
shifted it was global warming originally
when when James Hansen gave his
testimony before Congress in the summer
of 1988 you know and proposed these
potential tipping points and
catastrophic outcomes of our burning of
fossil fuel
we've gone from there to the United
Nations getting involved in the United
Nations setting up the whole the IPCC
and channeling all of this funding to it
and I think the consequence is is that
you know when you say again excuse me
we went from global warming to climate
change why did they not really use
global warming as a term anymore it's
mainly because for 15 years the average
global temperature is flatlined and this
is based upon you know the most accurate
like satellite surveys the IPCC
generally focuses only on ground-based
sensors which are subjected to a perhaps
some considerable bias because you know
you picture a ground-based sensors most
of them are sitting at airports when
these things were being put in
post-world War two the bulk of them 40s
and 50s into the 60s
many of these airports were rural they
were you know adjacent to small towns
they were surrounded by fields and farms
for us what's happened is the urban area
has encroached you know every when you
when you create streets pavement
buildings all of this absorbs heat right
and and no one has really done an
exhaustive study of the potential bias
that's introduced into the ground-based
sensors that part at least part of the
warming of these ground-based sensors
may have nothing to do with carbon
dioxide at all it may just have to do
with the fact that they're sitting next
to a huge parking lot you see and I mean
you know yourself if you walk out you
know if you're walking in a field and
then you walk onto a asphalt parking lot
immediately it's it's much much hotter
mmm you see Anthony watts was another
one of the dissenters that was demonized
is the only one who has really attempted
to exhaustively document the accuracy of
the ground-based sensors and what he's
come up with is that perhaps as much as
as 30 to 50 percent of the perceived
warming of the last century which is
about eight tenths
a degree centigrade is probably as a
result of that bias that sintra been
introduced by what's called the urban
heat island effect and all of the majors
say la has a urban heat island
mitigation program underway all the
major metropolitan cities are now trying
to mitigate the effects of this heat
because of all of the cement and the
buildings and the pavement and parking
lots they're always hotter than the
surrounding rural areas so the question
has been legitimately raised how much of
a bias has been introduced into the into
the ground-based sensors well when we
turn to the balloon sensors the
radiosonde balloon sensors in the
satellite sensors basically what they're
showing is that the average global
temperature has been flat for 15 years
well because of that and in many of the
key scientists like Phil Jones of the
IPCC has basically publicly admitted
yeah the when you look at the the every
temperature from that perspective it
hasn't warmed in 15 yeah now there are
regional pockets of warming and you know
records being set all the time because
local conditions will affect change
enormous ly just like I was talking
about the urban heat island effect is is
a local or regional condition but
because of the fact that the climate
hasn't warmed statistically
significantly in 15 years
now we don't talk about global warming
we talked about climate change but those
two terms are not interchangeable
global warming is a very specific model
of climate change which is that you've
got this 15 micron wavelength of co2 in
the atmosphere that's trapping infrared
radiation emanating from the earth right
okay but if you're talking about climate
change now suddenly you know our
umbrella goes much much huger and it now
encompasses all of these other things
that I was talking about and and to
question the consensus ideas to consent
to question that co2 is the
primary or sole driver of climate is not
to be a climate change denier Essie
because no I would challenge anybody he
even uses that term well show me an
example of any climate scientists no
matter where they fall in the argument
that is denying that the climate is
changing I mean anybody who has studied
the climate all knows that it has
changed dramatically and dynamically on
any scale you can look at whether it's
the decadal scale the Centennial or
millennial or beyond it changes on every
level and that's the thing we have to
recognize that if we stop burning fossil
fuels tomorrow we didn't drive another
car we didn't we shut down all the coal
plants I'm going to tell you this the
climate would not stop changing when you
see a story like here's one it's in the
news about US Senator Marco Rubio's
denial of manmade climate change should
play well with his tea party base whose
support he'll need if he indeed runs for
president in 2016 but in taking this
position
Florida's junior Republican senator
ignores the vast majority of the world's
climate scientists who say human
activity is contributing to climate
change and rising sea levels human
change no doubt there's no doubt that
human activity contributes to climate
change human activity again is one
variable in a very complex equation
I wish Mark Marco Rubio would keep his
mouth shut until he goes and spends
about six months or a year really doing
the homework because then he could talk
a little bit more intelligently about it
but that is the problem right it really
does take that long it does like he I
know you I've wanted I meet you at six
seven years ago something like that yeah
and you had already spent decades
observing the effects of climate change
and of asteroid Olymp acts and the
history of these things I mean the
amount of time just absorbing the
information so you can rattle it off
like this in a podcast I mean what the
fuck got you into this like the how did
you get down this rabbit hole
well this is an odd rabbit hole right
it's an odd rabbit hole it's a
fascinating rabbit hole I'm so thankful
not only that you've gone down but that
you're willing to exchange this
information with us or imparted on us
because it's it's a very different
perspective because I know you're not a
right-wing lunatic you're a very
science-based guy but you're you're
looking at this and the way you're
explaining it is incredibly rational and
incredibly frustrating to me that
there's not that many people that are
that are that are saying this well the
upside I think of the whole global
warming issue or the climate change
issue is this that if you know the thing
is is I made the point that even if we
stopped all fossil fuel consumption
tomorrow the climate is still going to
change and it's going to change
dramatically it's going to change
sometimes even catastrophic ly what we
need to do from here on out is basically
think about strategies of adaptability
if as a result of this whole issue even
even though I think it's miss based miss
you know miss applied if part of it that
comes out of this is that we begin to
develop strategies of adaptability that
would be a good thing if however we
focus so exclusively on carbon dioxide
to the exclusion of everything else that
could be a bad thing
because the climate is going to change
no matter what we do or where we go with
it the climate is going to change so you
can put up solar panels until the cows
come home
the houses that are on the beach in
Malibu are still gonna be underwater in
a hundred years well not necessarily
know I'm Sarah Lee so buy real estate in
Malibu well see the thing is if you look
at the I mentioned earlier that there
was a break in the in the Little Ice Age
of about 150 years that basically led to
the Renaissance right well we've been in
a recession of the Little Ice Age an
interruption of the Little Ice Age for
about 150 years and right now you know
and again the IPC one of the things that
frustrates me is that they basically
exclude solar physicists and solar
scientists
are essentially saying that insulation
levels insulation the amount of solar
energy penetrating the atmosphere is
that one of the lowest levels in in
thousands of years and I mean there are
our solar physicists that are saying you
know what we could be at the beginning
of another phase of the Little Ice Age
now if our co2 is helping to ameliorate
somewhat a return to little little ice
age that would be a good thing so muscle
cars are green yeah that's what I'm
getting out of this coal and muscle cars
are good for the forest well the
property the problem with coal is not so
much the co2 is to me it's just the
particulate matter right you know that's
a different question altogether the
pollution the pollution which is
horrific in China when they have coal
plants is you see these people that are
essentially walking it looks like
they're in the middle of a forest fire
they're walking those yeah it's just
dark everywhere that's a different issue
right no and and and I'm I consider
myself a conservationist in the respect
that we we basically need examples of
un-- pristine nature because ultimately
nature is the most powerful teacher and
we need examples we need places where
nature is just left alone to do its
thing without interference of human
beings we need clean air nobody has the
right to dump shit in the air that other
people have to breathe nobody has the
right to dump shit in the water that
other people have to drink to me those
are different questions and really where
the more of our focus should be rather
than these abstractions I have found of
course I've gotten some flak over the
last few years by saying some of the
things I've been saying here you know
that I've had people stand up and accuse
me of you know you just you say we can
just do anything we want we can just
destroy the earth which of course is not
the case and not saying that at all not
saying that at all
and when we begin to look at the bigger
context of this thing and we begin to
understand that the extraordinary
changes that this planet has been
through and even to some of the lesser
things in recent years Mount st. Helens
you remember when that erupted in 1980
tens of thousands
of acres were turned into a lunar
landscape right well if you read the
accounts of the scientists the
biologists the zoologists the ecologists
that have been studying what happened to
that decimated landscape in the
aftermath what you find out is they're
surprised and almost shocked at how
quickly nature recovered from that and
how quickly you know colonizer plants
moved in and was followed by a whole the
whole succession ecological succession
of reclaiming that land if you look at
the the Exxon Valdez disaster up in
Alaska in Alaska in that was over the
short term devastating to the local
ecology and yet what's interesting again
there have been several books written by
some of the lead scientists involved in
that talking about how remarkably quick
nature begin to reclaim and recover from
that and here's some irony where the
government forced Exxon to go in and do
its cleanup has actually suffered more
than the areas that were just left alone
for nature to reclaim that's fascinating
so the chemicals that they used in order
to break up yeah that was what the issue
with the Gulf as yeah right with those
dispersants that they were spraying over
the area they probably should have just
left the Gulf alone because you know
when you have submarine earthquakes they
can expel huge amounts of hydrocarbons
into the ocean Nature has been dealing
with the massive expulsion of
hydrocarbon into the oceans and into the
marine ecology for for millions and
millions of years you know it was bad
but I think you know what we'll see is
that the recovery time has been consider
than most people believed possible you
see I think what's what's really gonna
turn out in the end
looking at all this is that nature is
robust and when we begin to look at the
number of times that nature has been
disrupted by we've been talking about
asked
and comets and here's here's a
perspective for you you know at the peak
of the Cold War when US and the Soviet
Union were eyeball to eyeball with our
nuclear weapons on on high alert and we
had we had 10,000 weapons on our side
they had 10,000 weapons on their side
the total nuclear arsenal at the Times
had about 18,000 megatons of of energy
capable of being delivered 18,000
megatons now that means 18 million tons
of TNT the bomb that destroyed Hiroshima
was about 10,000 tons of TNT so a
hundred times a hundred Hiroshima bombs
would be one Megaton right now there was
about say 15 to 18,000 megatons total in
the arsenal of the superpowers during
the height of the Cold War had we
unleashed an all-out nuclear war and
fired every warhead that we had in our
Arsenal's at each other
15,000 warheads you know I mean 20,000
warheads 15,000 megatons it would have
been an environmental disaster
unprecedented in history you remember
the scenarios about nuclear winter right
because of all of the fires and the suit
and the particulate matter thrown into
the atmosphere it could literally bring
on a mini ice age right and and probably
cause without even the radiation caused
major collapse of the human population
right get this number in your head
15,000 megatons okay
now even a small asteroid impact or
let's say let's say the asteroid impact
that that struck the Yucatan there's a
simple formula that you can use when you
look at the crater size you take the
size of the crater and raise it
expressed in kilometers raise it to the
power of three point four and multiply
the result by 2.4 and what it's going to
give you is the energy yield in megatons
of that object strike
if I put in a hundred and eighty
kilometers into this calculator here
which is the diameter of the Yucatan
crater and I raise it to the three point
four power and then I multiply that by
the two point four power I get the the
Megaton yield all right that number
comes up to be 111 million megatons I
divide that by 15,000 and basically what
we have there is about equivalent to the
entire nuclear arsenal of the
superpowers eight thousand times over
eight thousand times over now what kind
of an environmental consequence would
there be to that well we saw that global
fire storms you know that this the
studies of the amount of soot at that
boundary layer shows that the amount of
biomass that went up in fire storms that
the KT boundary was about equivalent to
every plant on earth today going up in
fire right
you had tsunamis that were perhaps a
thousand feet in height you had global
earthquakes probably measured 10 to 11
on the Richter scale and you know how
the Richter scale works it's logarithmic
so that an 8.0 earthquake is 10 times
more powerful than a 7.0 9.0 is 10 times
more powerful in 8.0 an 11 point Oh
earthquake is going to be unimaginable
the whole framework of the globe would
have shaken you probably would have
massive failures on every fault line on
the planet now the KT event was the
middle of the five great extinction
events right there was Ordovician
Silurian there was the Permian Triassic
there was a couple more two of them were
more extreme than that now even even
much smaller than that right you know
that when they talk about a tipping
point you know are we talking about a
tipping point that could trigger a
climate change a disastrous catastrophic
climate change as being a few parts
million more
of co2 or is a tipping point really a
mile-wide asteroid slamming into the
earth at a hundred times the speed of a
rifle bullet that could be a tipping
point my friend and that has happened
thousands of times and hundreds of times
since we humans have been here hundreds
of times
hundreds of - hundreds of times and when
was the most recent one that was the
Holocene crater well probably it's
there's evidence emerging now that the
collapse of the Late Bronze Age
civilizations around four thousand two
hundred years ago may have been
precipitated by a series of impacts
there's evidence emerging that the
climate downturn that occurred between
536 and 540 ad that I talked about
earlier may have been triggered by a
series of multiple impacts one that
looks like it occurred off the coast of
Norway and another one that looks like
it occurred off the coast of New Zealand
like tandem impacts right around 536 ad
and and we're basically faced with the
idea now that literally impacts from
things from space maybe hundreds of
times more likely than anybody was even
imagining you know a generation ago so
we're essentially this civilization that
is banking on the knowledge that we've
accumulated over a very small amount of
time and as we're uncovering more and
more evidence more and more information
we're starting to realize our Eggman's
we're starting to realize how little we
know about our own history the history
of this particular species and how it's
interacted in this crazy volatile
environment of Earth and how many times
we've been hit by rocks yeah and see you
know a hundred years ago the assumption
was one of these these images of these
craters or impacts ah yeah that's that's
actually ten years old but it shows now
all the identified impacts and this is
ten years old so since then some new
ones have oh does a dozens more yeah and
since then has been discovery of this
new clear glass that they've found all
over Europe and all over Asia I think
are you referring to the possibly the
the thing that Graham was talking about
the the 13,000 year ago event I think I
think that's what it is what
I'm referring to is there was a
mainstream report about all these these
pieces of this very similar material to
what they find at nuclear blast yes
and that it was all over the place at
when they did the core samples around
12,000 years ago yes then that's exactly
what Graham's talking about yeah and and
yes the evidence is getting stronger and
stronger each year that there have there
may have been a multiple impact event
that terminated the ice age and this
still a very controversial idea because
the gradualists just don't want to go
there and this is probably what killed
off mass extinction of the woolly
mammoth mass extinction of the
saber-tooth Tiger yes and a series of
animals that they really have not
figured out why like there's there's
been all sorts of theories about why the
woolly mammoth went extinct and some of
them are ridiculous like that people did
it you know I'm glad to hear you say
that that's ridiculous idea well it's
ridiculous when you think about what
kind of people were around 12,000 years
ago and what kind of weapons they had
and what a fucking mammoth looks like
like Jesus Christ how many of them more
and the other thing that's ridiculous
about obviously when I say ridiculous
I'm ridiculous I shouldn't even be
making that statement I don't have done
very little research but the research
that I've read and the the people that
have questioned it have talked about the
mass graves where they've found these
animals that have died instantaneously
thousands of them and not consumed
either they don't show signs of
predation or of butchering they're there
they've died in full form full body yes
and they've massive massive massive
graveyards and you know for centuries
pristine mammoth tusks ivory have been
hauled out of the permafrost of Siberia
in trainload Lots
you know and this has gone into the
global ivory market literally for three
or four hundred years some estimates are
that there may have been as many as four
to ten million woolly mammoths worldwide
well most people don't realize that
right here in North America there were
three species of Provo city and or three
species of elephants during the Ice Age
Africa has one species Indian India has
another species we had three species
during the time what gobekli tepe was
being yes during the time elephants in
hey hi elephant here's another
perspective is that one that they found
what is that this is the berestov
commandment that was found in 1901
quick-frozen
yeah with flesh now at the time this
photograph was taken wolves had eaten
the flesh off of the skull that's why
it's it's it's bear but what you see
there immediately
dirty wolves yeah eating some million
year old meat it's gusting households
probably 13,000 Olli tell me so that's a
little not quite as bad as Miller also
but you can see the the the mammoth left
forelimb just in front of his face there
you see how it's and if in if Jamie
toggles back and forth between this
image and the next one you'll be able to
see yeah this was how the woolly mammoth
was found and so they took photos of it
when it was found like this and then
they left it alone and the wolf's came
and got it this is not this is a
reconstruction guys I believe in the
Leningrad Museum so what they did was
they took the remains of the woolly
mammoth and in taxidermists came in and
reconstructed but this shows the
position in which he was found sitting
on his haunches like that and at the
time that the woolly mammoth met his
demise he was eating flowering plants
right now it's important to keep that in
mind his stomach was full of about two
dozen different varieties of plants and
sedges and things that he had been
munching on up in Siberia at the time
that he that he met his death number of
interesting things the contents of his
stomach had not putrified right now
that's mysterious and the fact that his
his flesh was still edible at least by
wolves you know that the stories about
you know the scientists eating mammoth
burgers is probably made up but the
wolves definitely were able to eat the
flesh right it was described as still
being marbled almost as if it had just
been frozen you know a week ago but
since the time that the wooly mammoth
died
it had its whole carcass and that was a
6-ton wooly mammoth
so it had been frozen for how many
thousands and thousands of years and so
thoroughly frozen that the contents of
the stomach could not putrified now a
woolly mammoth of 6 tonnes has a lot of
internal heat right Clarence Birdseye
that the founder of Birdseye foods and
the inventor of the fast-freezing of
foods for preservation got involved in
examining and in speculating about this
wooly mammoth his conclusion basically
led to something like this in order to
prevent the contents of the stomach from
putrifying the entire carcass of the
woolly mammoth would have had to been
frozen through and through in 10 hours
or less now bear in mind that this
woolly mammoth was eating flowering
plants right now how cold would it have
to be to freeze a 6-ton woolly mammoth
in ten hours or less his estimate was
probably somewhere around 150 degrees
below zero
so from flowering plants to a hundred
and fifty degrees below zero in 10 hours
in 10 hours how what what causes
something like that well there's been
some speculation the speculation that I
found most interesting was possibly
volcanic gases that had been ejected up
into the stratosphere approached
absolute zero and because of the cold
fell back earth I think you could get
the same effect perhaps with gases
released from a disintegrating comet
nucleus it's still a mystery I mean
anything that anybody says at this point
is purely speculative
however it's clear that whatever this
mammoth underwent was disastrous in the
extreme you saw him sitting there on his
haunches right both of his hip bones
were broken which means that he was
slammed back onto his haunches
very violently he was also found with an
erect penis which means that he died by
suffocation
which meant that he was entombed
virtually instantly by the material that
later became the permafrost we were
talking about the Little Ice Age earlier
and I was talking about how the Little
Ice Age ended around 1850 well this guy
was found about 1901 after the climate
and Siberia had been warming somewhat
see and what happened was a part of a
clip a cliff that had been next to the
veresov career the Berezovsky River had
shifted its channel and eroded some of
the cliff face back and then one year
one warm spring there was a collapse of
the cliff face that exposed this mammoth
to the atmosphere Wow and at that point
is when the Wolves came in and began to
devour the flesh on the of the Scala see
so clearly this Morley mammoth is an
example of or indicative of some type of
a catastrophe
whether it was a global catastrophe or a
local catastrophe nobody knows but
clearly it was catastrophic
but that woolly mammoth there's only one
of dozens of examples of flash-frozen
Late Pleistocene mammals that died under
similar circumstances and these large
graveyards of mass extinctions of
thousands and thousands of animals what
are the best examples of them because I
know that I've seen some of them online
but I can't pull them up like I'm sure
you can I've got some right here if I
can get my laptop there pull Jamie pull
up look towards the bottom of the list
list you'll see Pleistocene the lost
world of the Pleistocene do you see that
no it's a it's a PowerPoint it's in that
list of the powerpoints that I gave you
I have some photographs you're freaking
me out I just want to tell you right now
you're freaking me out
well I get freaked out pretty easy but
freaking me out
well I actually Rosen mammoth I have to
confess that one of my objectives in
coming here was to try to freak you out
well you did it congratulations you're
successful I've been terrified of
Yellowstone for four years now I watched
some late-night documentary was a huge
mistake
one of the things I was about to go to
bed and I
just flipping through the channels and
they were going over this thing about a
caldera volcano and Yellowstone I was
like what the fuck's a caldera and then
they started talking about how it's what
was it something like 600 kilometers
wide or something crazy like that which
is something like 300 miles and they
were saying that they didn't even
discover it until they started doing
satellite imagery of of Earth and then
they realized that oh this was a giant
volcano that was so violent in its
eruption that it blew the mountain off
of it and it became this massive crater
and that it happens every six to eight
hundred thousand years ago and that the
last time it happened was six thousand
years ago yeah yeah so hopefully keeping
our fingers crossed we got another
hundred thousand years if we're lucky
yeah but see that's another aspect of
this component of the dynamic history of
planet Earth is these gigantic volcanic
eruptions there's been some interesting
work linking asteroid impacts with giant
volcanic eruptions as well and it would
it would make sense that um that that
the energy injected into the earth by a
major impact could trigger volcanic
eruptions we know that during the great
meltdown event of eleven to thirteen
thousand years ago that there were
enormous massive volcanic eruptions and
mount st. Helens for example was was
massively erupting at that time and I
have photographed I have felt some
photographs right here I don't know how
much time we have to look at some of
this but where I have gone out and I've
found thick layers of white volcanic ash
from Mount st. Helens sandwiched in
between these flood layers and and it it
shows that and it undoubtedly had have
been a response to the fact that you had
this enormous mass transfer of weight
that we were talking about earlier from
the continents back to the ocean and
when we go through I mean maybe it's
time to go through a few of these images
that I brought so you can begin to see
some of the consequences of this melting
and you begin to appreciate that
yeah there were these just enormous mass
transfers of weight unloading
in certain areas loading in other areas
this would clearly have a profound
effect on the subterranean stability and
could easily lead to major eruptions and
there was a spasm of major volcanic
eruptions globally at the time of the
the transition out of the Ice Age which
would only have added to the havoc of
that transition and why you know half of
the great species of megafauna
disappeared a megaphone is basically
defined as any any animal in this case
mostly mammals over 44 kilograms in body
weight which is about a hundred pounds
right so that would include us and if
you started thinking about all of the
animals globally worldwide there are
more than a hundred pounds depending on
how you divide up the species there
might be a hundred to twenty a hundred
and thirty different species and I'm
talking about the you know lions and
tigers and bears and elephants and
rhinos and hippos and moose and caribou
and dr. dot right down the line right
okay let's go back to the Ice Age the
extinction the loss of species at the
end of the last ice age was about
equivalent in number the loss of species
of mega mammals was about equivalent in
number to the number of species of mega
mammals that still exist
so in other words these events that
terminated the Ice Age basically
decimated half of the species of mega
mammals on earth half of the species
disappeared so if you are going to try
to effect an equivalent mass extinction
of species today you'd basically have to
eliminate every animal on earth over a
hundred pounds in body weight in order
to to get the equivalent of that mass
extinction episode of 12,000 13,000
years ago thats insane it's insane but
it's absolutely the truth I what is the
official like or mainstream explanation
for this it doesn't exist okay you
brought up the idea of it's called an
overkill which has been - domino theory
for four decades which is that human
hunters exterminated the woolly mammoth
and in some vague way the extermination
of the woolly
Ameth being at the top of the food chain
somehow had a ripple effect down you
know through the ranks of species and
somehow perhaps in an unaddressed way
resulted in the loss of all these other
species but they just don't address that
and the more you said that theory is
ridiculous
and that's an understatement I mean
you're talking about you know perhaps
bands of few hundred or maybe even a
thousand individuals migrant bands human
hunters coming in and somehow able see
you got to bear in mind that the
estimates of human population during
this time globally is less than the
estimates of the population of woolly
mammoths but somehow our ancestors were
able to wipe out 4 million to 10 million
wooly mammoths so fast that they
couldn't even reproduce so there was
only like 10 million people back then
that's well see that's based upon more
or less the conventional interpretation
now of course what we've been talking
about implies opens the door to their
possibility of there being a lot more
people and the mass extinction also
including a massive amount of human
beings as well yeah and there is some
interesting evidence emerging now that
there perhaps was a population collapse
between what is called the Clovis
culture and the Folsom culture the
Clovis culture appears in North America
to be what is believed to have been the
earliest culture and the there's a site
in New Mexico that was the first
discovery of the the association of
human artifacts meaning spear points and
arrowheads and things like that
along with extinct mammals right this is
Clovis New Mexico it's a very
interesting site I visited there about
six or seven years ago in order because
I was looking for this so-called black
math layer which has now been documented
at dozens of Clovis sites around North
American the black mat layer is this
unique layer that essentially separates
the Pleistocene from the Holocene and
it's full of soot it's full of iridium
nano diamonds microsphere olds and all
of these signature things that are
indicative of
kind of a cosmic event is this an image
indicative of that is that what this is
yeah that's kind of a blurry image but
right there you can see it up here too
so you can face the microphone yeah okay
yeah the white strip in the middle shows
the black matte layer that's exactly it
and what you see below it are the bones
of extinct mammals and what you see a
couple of thousand years later is bones
of extant mammals and nowhere above that
black matte layer do you find the bones
of the extinct mammals
what is extant it means dead that's no
still it still exists okay you know yeah
bears are extend I say you know that
slowly mammoths are extinct so there's a
very distinct line that can be
attributed to some sort of an event yes
some sort of interface something before
that they're all alive something after
that they're all dead they're all dead
and a massive amount of the larger
mammals gone got wiped off the face of
planet wiped off the face of the planet
North America lost about 75% of its
species of megamum holy shit and
three-quarters yeah there we there we go
there's some of them I love that thing
below that thing below what is that
fucking thing that giant ground sloth
that fucking thing is the Megatherium
Americana mitts the giant ground sloth
it was the size of an elephant oh my god
these are the glyptodont these are all
10,000 years ago not this guy these is a
dinosaurs obviously diagnosed Maximus is
the giant MOA this guy threw him in here
for raucous because he's just such an
awesome creature the terror bird right
hits the terror bird yeah I'm gonna
scroll back up stop scrolling Jim look
at that fucking bird
that's a seven-foot-tall lot bigger than
that was 8 9 foot tall yeah a bird that
doesn't fly so essentially a murderous
ostrich yeah this was the top of the
food chain during the Miocene really
yeah this was it this was the the
baddest ass predator on the planet for a
while
really yeah more so than a saber-toothed
tiger these guys existed before the
saber-tooth Tiger Wow
but they succumbed to one of these
global events you got a baron
mind if you take a census of all the
species that ever existed compared to
the species now it's conservative to say
that 99.99% of all species have become
extinct Wow
and in the ones that and of course most
of those had went extinct without any
help from humans at all it stops growing
what is that fucking thing that's a last
mo theory America Jesus Christ I mean he
you begin to appreciate it's like a
bulls that fucked a rhino yes wow that's
insane how big that is oh it was huge I
mean it was elephant size basically a
woolly rhinoceros the size of an
elephant and this is Cielo dontoh which
is the classic woolly rhinoceros and
there have been quite a few species of
these guys found that we're flash-frozen
and this is 12,000 years ago this thing
existed
yeah woolly rhinoceros yes and where
North America Jesus Christ that's
incredible and what is what's the
mainstream explanation for these things
going away good luck I'm trying to find
one I have looked there is none there
there is nothing they don't there's
nothing so is this something that they
just haven't formed any theories about
or they don't try to or it's been
ignored because it's not enough
information it's been ignored and here's
why at the dawn of earth science
geological science in the early 19th
century to a man every one of the
founding fathers of geology whether it
was you know William Buckland or Cuvier
or Sir James Hall or or Rodney Murchison
a dozen Sedgwick he could go right down
the line all of these guys from 1820 up
to about 1860 every one of them was a
catastrophist to a man every one because
these were guys basically who had not
been indoctrinated into any particular
interpretation of world history they
went out and they looked at evidence in
the landscape and their conclusion was
is you know something really
catastrophic has happened and then what
happened was you had Charles Lyell play
fair and Hutt James Hutton these three
came along and basically established the
doctrine of uniformitarianism as it's
called a mouthful right and basically
the idea of uniformitarianism was this
is that we look at modern processes to
explain ancient processes so if we see a
river eroding its bank moving sediment
creating a sandbar with that if we see
like during the the you know early 19th
century we were in the last phase of the
Little Ice Age so glaciers were receding
and these guys could essentially go up
there and look on a year-to-year basis
and see what was happening as the
glaciers were receding right so
basically what they then did was
extrapolated for modern processes to try
to explain all the ancient processes
this is the doctrine of
uniformitarianism okay it's a very
powerful model for understanding ancient
change however it became ensconced as
Dogma so that by the turn of the century
as we come right up to the to the
threshold of the 20th century it was now
considered unscientific to try to
explain anything in the past that we
couldn't see happening today right so as
we go into the 20th century this
gradualist Dogma became ensconced in
academia in every geologist from about
1900 up to about 1980 was thoroughly
indoctrinated into this idea of the
gradualism that all of the earth changed
that we see going on on the planet today
has occurred one grain of sand one drop
of water at a time and it was considered
to be very unscientific to begin to
evolve the founding fathers of geology
where a lot of them interesting were
theologians who often that's a number of
like Adam Sedgwick is a good example of
somebody who was a travelling theologian
a traveling minister right he was
traveling around England and he was
seeing things like the Thames River
Valley and he was saying that the Thames
flowed in this gigantic channel that was
completely outsized relative to the
river that was flowing in it and he says
that must have been from a he
huge flood well he was a theologian
right so he said Noah's Flood right well
as it turns out there are enormous
geomorphic effects of gigantic floods
all over the planet right we know that
now right in the 1800s they assumed that
if you saw effects of gigantic floods it
had to have been Noah's Flood well at
the same time that you had geological
gradualism on the ascent Geale a
biological gradualism came along in the
form of Darwinism and the two sort of
complemented each other and mutually
supported each other well if we've got
infinite time you know millions and
millions of years of gradual geological
change now that allows us millions and
millions of years for gradual biological
change and these two paradigms were
mutually reinforcing so now we come to
the 20th century and for the first three
quarters of the 20th century that was
the dogma that was indoctrinated into
the minds of every earth scientists
right and to vary from that was to be
pseudo scientific and you're trying to
revert back to biblical fundamentalism
if you start talking about giant floods
right well what happened was and then it
was left to people like Immanuel
Velikovsky it was not an earth scientist
he was a psychoanalyst and he wrote
several books in the mid-1950s where he
had gathered together in one place all
of this anomalous evidence from the
earth history that did not fit the
uniformitarian paradigm now his books
were popular successes but mainstream
science just slammed him slammed him and
said this guy is a nutcase
right well he did make some serious
missteps in trying to explain this
anomalous geological evidence for
catastrophe and it was those missteps
that they were able to focus on to try
to discredit him however the amassing of
evidence for catastrophes in Earth
history has held this the the test of
time and and what we see is what 1980
was a pivotal year that was a year that
three separate
teams published evidence showing that
the cretaceous-tertiary boundary the
dinosaur boundary was profoundly
catastrophic and that opened the door to
begin a reconsideration of Earth history
now at the same time with the advent of
the space program we are beginning to
realize that near-earth space is not a
completely empty place it's actually
densely populated by all kinds of things
see prior to the Apollo moon program it
was believed that most of the craters on
the moon if not all of the craters on
the moon were volcanic right post Apollo
the realization was is no they're not
volcanic their impacts of things from
space see now you look at the surface of
the Moon and I think the last image on
the Joe Rogan images there is going to
be a picture of the moon and you'll see
that it's littered littered thousands
and thousands and thousands of craters
and because it doesn't have an
atmosphere and because it doesn't have
plants we can actually see we think it's
happened and the point Joe is this if we
weren't able to strip away the biosphere
the the thick layers of sedimentary
rocks the oceans the earth would look
like the moon god damn it would look
like fucking moon so it's simply a
matter of time and perspective that we
we really well thank thankfully there's
people like you that are paying
attention to us but we with the amount
of time that people have been
videotaping things and writing books
this tiny little window there just
hasn't been enough time to really get a
real account of how often this takes
place because that that amount of time
although it's a grand amount of time
compared to our lives the life of an
individual for the life of the planet
it's nothing it's a perspective issue
it's a perspective exactly exactly and
and this is one reason why I'm an
advocate for moving forward and
essentially becoming a cosmic
civilization you see I came of age
during the the heyday of the mercury and
Gemini Gemini and Apollo programs and
you know that
the one thing when I look back and I go
we own what one of the last times that
it was really proud of my country was
when we put those men on the moon you
know when we planted our American flag
on the moon and I really believe back in
1969 1970 that we were America's destiny
was to move the human species into this
grander cosmic environment and then of
course you know the Vietnam War came
along and other priorities and money got
shifted in a Nixon administration
shifted huge amounts of money away from
the space program the timetable that was
set out that we were going to have a
permanent lunar base by the end of the
70s first manned mission to Mars before
the 80s was over perhaps independently
self-supporting colonies in space by the
year 2000 Mara was a junior in high
school when Kubrick's 2001 a Space
Odyssey came out have you ever seen it
sure yeah
1968 nobody had any it was no stretch of
the imagination to assume that by 2001
yeah there were going to be orbiting
hotels in space right that could have
happened but we lost our vision we lost
our will and we just got sidetracked you
know I remember in the 70s talking to
people about the potential of colonizing
space using the materials and resources
found in space and the the knee-jerk
response I always got was well we've got
too many problems here on earth we got
to solve those problems first well my
response to that was well good luck
because you're basically talking about
altering human nature right and it's
gonna take something more than just some
policy to alter human nature what it's
going to take is some serious
consciousness excursions perhaps people
going to space you know here we had
these astronauts I met Edgar Mitchell
years ago he's a Mason he came to my
lodge years ago Edgar Mitchell who was
one of the astronauts he was one of the
many astronauts that went into space and
like his in Freemason as in Freemasons
everybody freaks out and he say
freemason I know loominatee
more nonsense and we should have a whole
session just to do
with that ridiculous nonsense next time
freak me out about that okay
Edgar Mitchell when you met him does it
was he talking about aliens no no
billions no he was talking about going
into space and seeing God whoa crazier
than aliens
yeah crazier than aliens he's God made
aliens perhaps so he saw God in the
sense that he got a sense
I mean without even saying God he got a
sense of the the the grandness great
universe yes and and yes and and you
know the potential role of humans in
that have you ever been to the Keck
Observatory in Hawaii no I haven't the
Keck Observatory in Hawaii is a very
unique place because it's on the Big
Island of Hawaii and it's very high up
in altitude and when you get up there
you actually drive through the clouds I
took my family there several years ago
and we were bummed out because I got so
cloudy we're not gonna be able to see
anything but then you pop through the
clouds as you continue to drive and the
view is magnificent and it is to this
day one of the most intense experiences
consciousness expanding experiences I've
ever had I believe it without drugs yeah
you know I mean it was like a
psychedelic experience it really was
because the the amount of that's the
Keck Observatory you see how it's above
the clouds when you that's a daytime
shot I've see Jamie see if you could
pull up a knife nighttime shot because
you know they set the camera aperture to
capture the I didn't I had a regular
camera I couldn't I couldn't really
capture the the actual stars themselves
but you see the Milky Way like not like
that it's way more intense than that
that you see the Milky Way in its full
form you see all right yeah and there's
so many stars it's so shocking you
you're immediately forced to accept the
reality that we're in space whereas it's
so easy to deny when all you see is the
moon and a couple little dots like
whatever man I'm in Hollywood I gotta go
to work and you drive you get on the hop
that's what it's like yeah and it's so
it's it's and that's just a photograph
and that's you know obviously there's
some doctoring going on because I don't
know what those lines are but it's
insane how intense it is it's insane
and it's it's it's right above you yes
right above us all the time that's what
I love about the high desert plateaus
you've got this dry atmosphere and it's
like literally you can almost reach out
and touch the Stars you know we were
talking about
you've never been to LA before this is
your first trip to LA because when
you're in California you just go to the
Mojave and stare at space
well I stare at space and I stare at the
rocks yeah the rocks below my feet and
the Stars over my head yeah how did you
get involved in the exploration of all
this stuff well you know I guess I
better time to come out of the closet I
think I did a little too many drugs back
in the 60s and I think he did the right
amount yeah I think you're being hard on
you actually actually in 1969 so of
course I was I was raised in rural
Minnesota and where we grew up we lived
on the shores of a puddle a meltwater
puddle left over from the receding of
the glaciers yeah call it a puddle it's
I call it a puddle it was three-quarters
of a mile long it was just you know
Minnesota Wisconsin's got about twenty
five thousand lakes and every one of
them has leftover meltwater puddles from
the recession of the glacier so I can
still remember being like 6 or 7 years
old and my dad telling me you know once
upon a time this was thousands of feet
under the ice and that's how this we had
land on the edge of this lake and as a
kid I used to sit in my backyard and
fish for you know sunfish and crappies
and Bowl heads that's what I don't
understand it interrupts your story for
just one second how the fuck does that
happen where 10,000 years ago it's a
glacier 10,000 years later there's fish
in there uh-huh
where the fuck of the fish coming from I
don't know but they were there but how
where's the largemouth bass come from
how what's the all this with the lake
trout in the Great Lakes where the fuck
do they come from
if 10,000 years ago that was frozen
solid
yes frozen solid where the fuck the lake
trout come from I'll have to get to work
on that Joe cuz I don't know the answer
I need to know man I'm freaking out how
about northern pike
I mean northern pike you go to
Saskatchewan PA fly in from all over the
world to go fishing up there because
they have this massive population of
beautiful northern yeah hike these big
that was frozen yes
cess kanpai
a mile of ice what the fuck man I'm
freaking out
that doesn't even make sense yeah so you
saw this so you were a kid I was a kid
growing up with that landscape so I got
fascinated by it but in 1969 I went to a
rock an outdoor rock concert that was at
an airport called Eden Prairie that's in
the just outside of the Twin Cities
Minneapolis and it's on a series of
Bluffs that overlooks the Minnesota
River Valley right of course I'm stoned
out of my gourd and I was taking a break
from the music and the ladies and
everything and I went over and was
standing on this Bluff and and Jamie if
you would pull up I think it's near
though the end of the pictures I brought
for Joe I have a beautiful example of
scale invariance and this is going to be
similar to what I saw and and when you
see it that's that's like the 25 images
that's labeled for Joe it'll be towards
the end it's a picture of the Snake
River find it Wow the Snake River
wait'll you see this Joe now this is an
example of scale invariance now what
that means is that you know you know
yeah here we go now look at this what
you see here where can folks they're
just listening to this go and see these
images is there are they on your website
I think this one is on my website okay
yeah I think this one's not so the Snake
River you see the Snake River scale and
variance meaning that the the river at
the bottom obviously you see the lines
all around it where it indicates that
there was a much much larger body of
water at one point much bigger this the
modern Snake River is about 50,000 cubic
feet per second right at the end of the
last ice age the river here was about 30
to 40 million cubic feet per second so
was that because of the melting glaciers
the force of the vessel this particular
was not directly fed by the melting
glaciers it was the result of the
catastrophic overflow of Lake Bonneville
which was the result of massive
prolonged torrential rainfall that just
drowned all the deserts of the
southern of the Western and southwestern
United States and there was an overflow
a spillway out of the Lake Bonneville
basin in northern Utah and it spilled
over into the Snake River plain of Idaho
30 to 40 million cubic feet per second
cut this channel now you'll notice that
the modern Snake River occupies a small
channel within the big channel that's
scale invariance the big river would
have been about equivalent to six to
seven hundred of the modern Snake rivers
and what you're seeing here is an
example of scale invariance see the the
little is superimposed up on this big
see now in 1969 I was standing on a
bluff overlooking the Minnesota River
Valley similar to this right looking
down at the little Minnesota ribbon of
the Minnesota River and seeing it in
this huge channel and I had an aha
moment I had an aha moment and I
realized I saw then that this channel
that this bluff I was standing on had
once been the bank of a gigantic river
thousands of times bigger than the
modern Minnesota River but I I didn't
know it rationally in the sense that it
took me another ten or fifteen years of
study and research before I could go
back and say yeah what my initial
instinct looking out and seeing this
matching set of Bluffs for five miles on
the other side and seeing this small
version of it in the modern river that I
was right that I remember one time in
the 80s I was giving a talk on that and
I there was a geologist in the audience
and he got up and no no no no no no that
that big channel that was millions of
years millions of years it took for that
channel to form and I said no I don't
think so
and what happened was is by him
challenging me it really you know I said
okay you know like an EM you know an MMA
fighter getting challenged says okay I'm
gonna take you on you know I rose to the
occasion and I spent literally years
doing research on Glacial geomorphology
on Paley
hydrology and of course at the end of
the thing I knew that I was my instincts
were absolutely correct that yes now
there is solid scientific documental
verifiable evidence that this whole
channel of the Minnesota River Valley
was filled brim full with water at the
end of the last night so when he was
saying it was millions of years he's
saying that same exact channel of water
had never varied and that it had just
cut through over millions of years very
slowly yes but does that sort of that
doesn't seem rational because of the
width no it doesn't you'd have to and it
doesn't it doesn't makes so this goes
along with what you were talking about
earlier that the idea the the ideas of
science were that everything had taken
place much like evolution on a very
gradual pace exactly is this the Grand
Canyon as well no I would here's what I
would say about the Grand Canyon I think
that the Grand Canyon is presently we
can observe it that we can observe the
Colorado River eroding the Grand Canyon
however I think that the erosion of the
Grand Canyon is not uniform it's episode
ik which means that the Grand Canyon has
probably been there between two and five
million years because for one thing the
Grand Canyon wouldn't start eroding
until the Colorado Plateau had lifted up
and 10 to 12 million years ago the rim
rock of color of the Colorado Plateau
was lime stones which implies a shallow
marine environment right now when it's
down at marine at sea level it's not
going to Road it's not until the whole
plateau lifts up between five and ten
million years ago that the down cutting
can start so my take on the Grand Canyon
would be that what happens is as we have
you have to understand us now this is
this is I think now is the is the the
merging emerging paradigm there are two
modes of change the gradualist mode that
we've seen dominating through you know
the last few hundred years at least
since the advent of modern science and
then the if you want to call it the
catastrophic mode where as much change
it's compressed
into a few years or months or sometimes
even days or weeks as normally would
take thousands and thousands of years
when I look at the Grand Canyon what I'm
seeing there is episodes of catastrophic
erosion probably stretching back over
two and a half million years remember I
said the Pleistocene was about two and a
half million years what characterizes
the Pleistocene from the previous
Pliocene is this alternating succession
of glacial and interglacial ages this
swinging back and forth between these
two extremes those episodes of
transition appear to be profoundly
catastrophic and they are associated
with things like massive storms massive
rainfalls rising and falling of sea
levels on an extreme basis and I think
it's that that has created the Grand
Canyon predominant in fact the inner
Channel I know if you've ever seen Grand
Canyon yes yeah okay there's an inner
gorge I could guess that that inner
gorge is probably less than a hundred
thousand years old and probably a lot of
it was cut 13,000 years ago Wow and so
that's when the Pleistocene ended
somewhere around ten thousand years ago
yeah ten to thirteen thousand years ago
Wow
yeah and that's a that's not a real
picture is it no it seems like an
artist's rendition yeah I have pictures
somewhere in there we're still where you
get a sense yeah now the the
accumulation of the sedimentary rocks
yeah took hundreds of millions of years
but that's one process the down cutting
the erosion of the Canyon is a different
process so again it comes to a matter of
perspective that we're almost incapable
of let me I think you know academically
and you you could sort of explain how
all this takes place and explain what's
happening but in our minds our our
perspective of living a hundred years
looking back it's very difficult to go
back 20 years ago and I remember when
that happened while barely but this is
that ain't shit compared to the earth
the earth the earth is just constantly
changing and
our knowledge of human history we have
this sort of static view and
occasionally we have that meteor that
flew over Russia recently and blew up in
the sky and everybody's like whoa what's
with that and then it stops and then
nothing go back to work right go back to
work go back to sleep
yeah and that thing that blew up over
Russia that was that was a spec and
there's nothing and then nurse
Tunguska which blew up in the early
1900's 1908 June 30th 1908 which just
flattened thousands and thousands of
acres oh well let's see it was eight
hundred square miles and there 640 acres
per square mile so it flattened half a
million acres oh my god million acres
and that was the energy of that was
about equivalent to a 15 Megaton bomb
Paula yeah there's an image of Tunguska
just all the trees completely flat and
completely flat up a few look at that
gangster tree just still stand-in there
how's that happen I know it's just like
every now and then it's one bad
motherfucker tree that's how people stay
alive right yeah because just like
everybody else died or most things died
and most of the species died a few
people figured out a way to make it and
then they decided to have babies what a
bunch of crazy fuck
could you imagine giant asteroid hits
kills everybody rotten people and wooly
mammoths all over the place and you're
still horny
you're still horny and you make a baby
like Wow and you raise it and that baby
makes more place what does it say in the
book of Genesis you know be fruitful and
multiply now get this the word replenish
the earth replenish the earth and subdue
it I think clearly that's a clear hint
that saying this is not the primordial
creation it's a subsequent creation to
something a previous order of things why
use the word replenish be fruitful and
multiply it would make sense if if the
human population crashes in the wake of
a global catastrophe and we're down
hovering at the threshold of viability
where you know we could become extinct
if just anything else happens and we
want to we
want to preserve our species well the
probably the thing we need to be doing
is having lots of sex mmm does I'm
talking about yeah I know I mean we need
to do lots of screwing and we need to
screw and make scientists that figure
out how to get us off this rock
yeah well see be fruitful and multiply
and make spacious replenish the earth
and subdue it what the hell is that does
this say subdue it subdue it that's in
Genesis oh yeah it's in Genesis what the
hell are they talking about they're
choked the earth well I see that's the
way it's been interpreted I think it's
in being interpreted to say look you
guys are the only rational species down
there you've got these big brains you
know you got to be born before you you
know it takes you years and years to
actually get where you can survive on
your own because you've got these big
fucking brains see so we're kind of like
nature's answer to all of this you know
only one species right now has the
ability to intercede and prevent the
next global catastrophe and that's us do
we rise to that challenge or do we say
well we're gonna let nature run its
course and if 50% of the species
disappear civilization is over we go
back to the Stone Age struggling for
existence well so be it that's what's in
the cards or do we say you know what we
could but in one generation be
harvesting the resources of asteroids
which we could be if we had the will and
the vision and the thing is is that the
most dangerous asteroids that our are
out there it's the closer they get to
the earth the more accessible they are
and and you see we already could be
harvesting the resources laughter I mean
asteroids are loaded with precious
metals and ores and hydrocarbons there's
virtually nothing that we are now mining
from the earth that we couldn't mined
from asteroids Wow
what does that suggest to you well and
and think about this if if I like to
kind of imagine a scenario suppose we
had discovered remember shoemaker-levy 9
yes okay discovered in March of 1996
within about eight weeks of observations
the astronomers were able to
predict that these fragmenting pieces
were going to orbit the Sun and come
back and be crossing the orbit of
Jupiter at exactly the time that Jupiter
was there right there was gonna be a
t-bone collision it was like two
vehicles coming to the intersection at
the same time and they were able to
predict that right down to the almost to
the minute to the hemisphere what if we
discovered that there's an asteroid
orbiting the Sun out there that's got
our number on it and it was in a strike
the earth in three years or ten years or
twenty years or whatever what would be
our response to it what would we do I
think globally it would be there would
have to be some sort of a collective X
effort yeah
the scientists from China and Russia and
all these different various countries
that have vast technological
capabilities would probably get together
and have some sort of an agreement I
would think that that would have to
happen and it would fact it would
probably make our petty human conflicts
pale into insignificance if we were
faced with the demise of our
civilization or even possibly our
species but suppose we discovered it and
it's coming in a couple of years and
there's no time to respond what could we
do well perhaps if we had a long enough
lead time we could actually die Fleck
all we need to do is as an asteroid
that's on a collision course with the
earth all it has to do is be nudged a
little bit in a direct hit can be a wide
miss see that's all we would have to do
is just nudge it a little and there's
various potential technologies whereby
we could do that but what if we didn't
have enough lead time and we knew that
that it was gonna slam into the earth
and for a thousand years gonna be havoc
what would we do well perhaps we could
go build a base on the moon or build a
something in space that would allow
humans to survive at least until the
dust settled enough that we could return
and begin to replenish the earth you
know what a bummer it would be if he had
a base on the moon and everyone was
living there and you've watched the
earth blow up total bummer but it would
be even bigger bummer if you didn't have
it and you were sitting on the earth
oh and that that's it man that's all she
wrote how many different times do you
think this has happened while human
beings are alive and what how the great
speculation has always been when they
see the pyramids or when they see any
incredible structures that we really
haven't totally explained how they built
what like Baalbek in Lebanon you know is
what how advanced were they how advanced
were they before the shit hit the fan
well it seems to me that in order to you
know you gotta go
why would primitive cultures move rocks
that way two hundred to a thousand tons
apparently with impunity they were doing
it all over the planet right well why
would why would somebody be motivated I
mean you know like again I'm a builder
so I know how much work it takes to move
even a you know without a crane without
modern technology to move a beam into
place that weighs a ton right well you
know we've got stones in some of these
ancient temples that weigh hundreds of
tons and again all over the world
it seems to me difficult to imagine that
they didn't have some kind of a
technology that we've forgotten what
that technology is I couldn't say but it
would sure seem to me that there would
be no motive for moving you know five
hundred tons stones unless you had some
convenient way of doing it or if not a
convenient way of doing it just explain
how an inconvenient way they could have
done it when you get to something like
the Acropolis or the Parthenon that's on
the Acropolis right is that what is the
part that crop list is the stone and the
Parthenon is about song propolis is the
heel with the complex on it and the
apartment on is one of those in impulse
the Acropolis is a man-made construction
that has massive massive stones that
they just don't explain yeah yeah I mean
they're there they're in there in Cuzco
in South America you know they're in
Egypt
yeah there it is the baalbek one is
actually probably even more impressive
shame you see if you could pull that up
the stones of Baal how do I spell it be
double al be ek and there there's these
stones are just unbelievably big yeah
and no explanation for how they move
them cut them quarried them got them
into place and what year it was all done
right that's a one vision of it or a
picture of it but if you search for
others he is actually a close-up of the
actual stones themselves and they show
people standing next to stone so you get
a perspective of it much much taller
than a human being
in fact like I think 10 or 11 feet tall
in some places like there's one rock
just like fuck remove that but some of
the stones see that's not a good one
Jamie there's there some where you can
see the massive amount of stone that was
in each individual one some of them are
literally building sized and it's just
an individual stone and yeah there's one
like what the fuck man what the fuck is
that that is so big
yeah it's they moved that they cut that
quarried it and moved it yeah I mean I
don't know how many people they had to
do that but boy that doesn't seem like
something that a society which is really
concerned with feeding itself is is
going to get done right
what so when you see like the
constructions of the great pyramids
which is one of the great wonders of the
world and to this day they're always
trying to come up with ways that they
did it but the sheer size and to put it
into perspective if you cut and I think
the number is 10 stones a day 2 6 2
million three hundred thousand-plus
stones in the Great Pyramid of Giza and
if you cut and place ten a day it would
take you six hundred sixty-four years
yeah I you know yeah having seen the
Great Pyramid and many of the temples in
Egypt I'm convinced that they had to
have some means that we've forgotten
for transporting these stones you know
they may have used fairly primitive
methods to quarry the stones but when it
comes to transporting the stones you
know I mean we could imagine that
they're putting them on rollers and
dragging them over you know Hill and
Dale but again you got to go really all
over the whole planet it's just it's one
of those things it's like the demise of
the frozen William amis there's just no
real explanation and and we can invoke
explanations that are basically designed
to avoid the implications of admitting
that there may have been advanced
knowledge scientific knowledge in
prehistory hmm and that somehow or
another that knowledge was lost whether
it was because of the burning of the
Library of Alexandria or whether it was
just a cataclysmic event that wiped out
a massive amount of the population and
what was remaining was buildings like
that yeah those things survived and then
people tried to recreate them people
eventually figured out some of the
techniques and made similar structures
but not over a period of a thousand
years or 2,000 years but maybe twenty
thirty thousand years mm-hmm that's
always been the work of Graham Hancock
the the the ideas they bounced around
and I remember there was that Charlton
Heston narrated documentary on the
Sphinx where they had gone into great
detail about the erosion they brought on
the geologist Robert Schoch from Boston
University I know Robert yeah I want to
get him on the podcast too he's a
fascinating cat yes and he concluded
that the temple the Sphinx the enclosure
where it was cut out of shows thousands
of years of erosion by rainfall which
there wasn't rainfall in the Nile Valley
before 9,000 years ago so this predates
the pyramid construction the average or
the the conventional dating of the
pyramid there it is right there the some
of his explanations it predates the what
the conventional date of the
is by more than 5,000 years oh I'm
convinced and I've had conversations
with Robert where he will basically say
he's got one number for public
consumption but he's perfectly willing
to admit that perhaps this makes is much
much older than that and I what's the
dark number what's the crazy number oh I
think the crazy number is tens of
thousands of years if you pull up it's
not that crazy though now it was kind of
crazy when that Charlton Heston document
and documentary was around but now that
they found gobekli tepe
and they know that fourteen thousand
twelve thousand years ago whatever it
was they were absolutely building these
enormous immense structures that would
be what eight thousand years seven
thousand years earlier than the pyramids
mm-hmm mm-hmm not that not that big a
deal not that big of a deal they the
conventional dating of the Great Pyramid
Giza is 2,500 BC which may be correct
but it still doesn't mean that the
Sphinx wasn't way way old and way older
than that exactly and you know I'm
convinced having seen it firsthand that
that erosion is water induced I've
looked at a lot of erosion over the
years and you know it's got the classic
parabolic profile that you would expect
if you started out with an initially
square Jamie
open up the PowerPoint show entitled
Cataclysm os-- global super flood
cataclysmic global super fraud that's my
new band it's gonna be my new band go
for it man cataclysmic radical is most
was the Greek term for the destruction
of the world by water oh wow it's from
where we get our term Cataclysm whoa and
their term C you know the Greeks
believed that there were alternating
destructions of the world by water and
fire right heterosis
was the term Greek term for the
destruction of the world by fire Wow and
cataclysmic of water on this stuff is so
unbelievably fascinating because there's
no way that you can attribute all of
this stuff I mean these
all of these ancient structures there's
no way you can attribute it to what we
know about their culture we don't know
enough there's just not enough evidence
there's not enough we don't know enough
about ancient Egypt or you know or their
construction methods there's so much
there's so much thinking like there's so
much guesswork it's so much you know
when you look at these giant structures
and you wonder like what what were they
doing how did they do this who were they
like it's so fascinating I would just I
would love to be able to go back in time
it's a giant bulletproof bubble I know
I'm just hover over ancient Egypt yeah
what's going on back then I know why did
you guys know Jamie go to you've got a
global super flood what is this image go
to slide 58 a slide the infamous slide
58 hangar 18 slide 58 oh wow that's
beautiful
okay that's amazing now what you can see
there is you got to get it in that's a
microphone get on the microphone there
the valley temple look up there oh yeah
okay the valley temple with stones
quarried from the ditch around the
sphinx you got to remember what the
Sphinx is that originally it was a
yardang which is a which is a limestone
outcrop that sticks above the
surrounding landscape the yardang was
the head of the Sphinx everything else
was below now go to the next slide Jamie
okay there you can really see the ditch
surrounding the Sphinx and the layers
forming the Sphinx body correspond to
the layers in the surrounding ditch now
wanted to me you'll notice the
scaffolding next to the Sphinx they're
there they're undertaking these
campaigns of rests quote/unquote
restoration gross but what they're
actually doing is they're covering up
the real message of the Sphinx yeah why
are they doing now why are they
bothering to try to rebuild the phone I
don't know it's so stupid like wait
you're not rebuilding it you're building
new shit yeah you're just refacing it
yeah
with new
stealth so gross but at least nobody is
messing with the quarry walls where you
can see the water erosion so effectively
displayed go to the next slide Jamie now
what we see here is an abandoned quarry
it's hard to tell the scale here because
that opening is like 40 feet high but if
you look at you see the striations in
the rock wall mm-hmm okay this is where
they quarried the blocks right and
remove the blocks go to the next slide
Jamie okay this kind of shows the
methodology that they use they would
create these separation trenches they
would usually go by the the natural bed
bedding layers of the rock go to the
next slide and you'll see here here's
the presumed process where they're
cutting a separation trench and there's
a block about to be quarried there and
then you can see there would have a
stack of four blocks there and these
blocks are enormous several tons oh yeah
that block there would be looks like
it's probably about four by eight by
probably ten so like 320 cubic feet at
160 per so or 180 so you're looking at
about fifty seven thousand pounds
divided by two thousand so yeah but -
yeah bout 30 tons see it's about 30 tons
for that rock right there now go to the
next slide 30 tons mmm okay now the
reason I'm showing you this is because
this is the process they would have used
to quarry the blocks away from the the
surrounding the Sphinx and exposed a
quarry wall well at the time that quarry
wall was exposed
it would have been essentially a flat
surface with this slightly stepped
profile like we saw in the photograph
right now go to the next slide right so
there's now would be a cross-section
with all of the blocks removed okay go
to the next slide and what we have here
is stone pick marks in a limestone lets
you go quarry from Rama seed x about
twelve
hundred BC so about 3200 years ago so
here's a limestone face of a quarry
that's been exposed for 3,200 years and
seems like they used some sort of a
chisel - yeah exactly the the pick marks
are still visible go to the next slide
okay here's stone pick marks in a quarry
from the early New Kingdom circa 15 so
3500 years ago you can actually
determine the type of tool that they
used to quarry the rocks the picks are
the chisels go to the next one based on
the marks that are based on tomorrow's
yeah and here you see that the chisel
marks made or pick marks made by stone
picks in an Old Kingdom limestone quarry
2,000 years BC so here's a 4,000 year
old quarry that's been sitting exposed
to the desert elements and the pit marks
are still visible on the face now go to
the next slide now here's the Sphinx go
to the next slide and look at that
quarry wall yeah that's crazy it's crazy
yeah now supposedly this quarry wall is
only a few centuries older than that
last picture we just saw where we could
see the pic marks
does that make sense well the only way
it would make sense as if there was a
vastly different type of stone well it's
not though it's it's the same it's it's
a well indurated limestone Robert can
tell you all about the composition of
that stone the the composition does vary
though oh yeah like some of its more
dense than others and that's you're
conceive of the changes yeah and you can
see that that indented layer about
halfway up is going to be a softer
limestone absolutely it certainly looks
to the layman and I'm clearly a layman
but it certainly looks like like water
fissures like Oh fissures that are even
rainfall even to the trained eye it
looks like water but some legit
Egyptologists and even legit geologists
have tried to attribute this to wind and
sand well again you know Robert has
shown pictures of the comparison of wind
erosion to sand or water erosion they
don't look the same so the only reason
to attribute this to wind and sand it's
not based on the scientific evidence of
what it looks like when there's water
erosion it's
confirm or to conform with the known or
established timeline of construction yes
and that's why I showed you those
examples of other core like that Old
Kingdom quarry that's almost the same
age as this so it's actually really not
scientific to try to attribute it to
wind and sand it's just your what you're
doing is confirming to confirmation bias
you have you have an idea in your head
and you're trying to to make this really
odd erosion fit into that but that
doesn't look like wind and sand go to
the next line literally Jamie Oh
jam-band that's good okay so there's the
depth of the of the of the ditch it's
about 22 feet and air shows each of the
layers like if you look at layer 11
that's gonna be a softer limestone its
eroded deeper right now go to the next
slide and you'll see what I've done is
superimposed what the original profile
would have looked like hmm and there's
been an enormous amount of rock
limestone rock removed and we know the
profile would have looked like that
because the stones that were quarried
are what make up the Sphinx and Valley
temples right but noes have been eroded
as well but unfortunately they've
covered that up with this reconstruction
well most likely most likely and I think
Robert would confirm this that the
limestone blocks that formed those
temples were sheathed in hard granite
hmm whereas this quarry wall was not it
was exposed and then there's also the
issue of the Sphinx head itself which
seems to have been altered and this this
is a time line thing that folks may or
may not know but there's been the Egypt
changed quite a bit
I mean Egypt ancient Egypt was around
for thousands and thousands of years and
at some point they were conquered by the
Nubians and the the the more African
what we think of as traditional African
faith obviously Egypt as part of Africa
but the more traditional looking African
faces is what you see in the current
face in the temple the Sphinx so
probably what had happened is a later
date Pharaoh said you don't want to fuck
this lion I want my face up there so
they put the face of this
probably Katherine mm-hmm and I think
both Jana Anthony West and Robert Schoch
would concur with that's why there's so
little erosion on that face right
because that face is only a few thousand
years old and why it would be
disproportionately small compared to the
rest of the body Wow so fascinating I
just I would give so much to know what
they knew then I any point in time to go
back in human history and just to be
able to observe that would be the time
that the just the middle of Egypt I
would love to see what it looked like
before they raided it and took off for
folks I don't know it was covered in
smooth limestone and they they cut it
all up to build Cairo they raided it
yeah there was an earthquake that
flattened Cairo and you know they had
attempted to penetrate the Great Pyramid
prior to that without success but
apparently the earthquake which I think
happened I think it happened in the 12th
century
loosened a few rocks from near the top
of the pyramid that allowed them to get
some levers in there and begin to pry
them loose so I've read a bunch of
fucking assholes talk about vandalism
that get this whether this is true or
not we have no way of knowing but there
are many many Arabic accounts and counts
of early travelers and pretty much they
all unanimously declare that the entire
outside of the pyramid was inscribed now
think about that what in the hell would
that have been telling what kind of
message was that that was being sent to
the future that must have been amazing
yeah I get I get my my hair stands up on
my legs just thinking about inscribed
yeah hey listen there's rocks in space
and occasionally they land and when they
do you're fucked build one of these get
inside wait for further instruction it's
amazing that they're there I mean if
that thing existed Robert Schoch is
corrected and that thing existed before
the the Holocene events mm-hmm those are
the only types of structures that would
still be here yeah kind of fuck did
people make it through there I wonder
what the number was well I'm gonna tell
you
Adam and Eve story here's my theory on
it you know all over the world we have
traditions about caddis catastrophes and
cataclysms and giant floods all over the
world they've come down to us and
there's a lot of deviation but there's
also a lot of similarity in them um the
idea that a small group had some kind of
foreknowledge you know whether it was
knowing the Bible or Deucalion in the
Greek myths or eating a piston in the
Sumerian myths or is this a thrissoor
manu I mean the the the culture heroes
had survived these great cataclysmic
floods are in the dozens and dozens
right American Indians had prolific
traditions about giant floods when when
George Caitlin the famous Indian artist
spent decades of his life going around
living with various Indian tribes like
40 years painting and in writing about
him very interesting quote in one of his
books he says that they're widely
divergent with traditions and language
and customs and so on but of a hundred
and twenty tribes that he visited they
all had one thing in common that they
were descended from survivors of some
gigantic cataclysmic event that's
American Indians you find it in North
America you find it in South America you
find it in two Polynesian islands you
find it in Australia Japan I mean it's
around the entire planet this idea and
now modern science is confirming what we
assumed was merely some kind of
superstitious nonsense of you know
pre-scientific illiterate barbarians and
we're realizing that those myths and
those stories and epic tales that are
handed down for centuries and centuries
actually contain hard scientific truth
from surviving eyewitnesses well if
these craters actually do exist and they
do right although seeing craters
undeniable the nuclear glass throughout
Asia and Europe undeniable human beings
were alive then yes
and if human beings were alive then they
got fucked up there's no doubt about it
yeah they did they would have suffered
normally and just like you know if if
you know if 3/4 of the species of
animals in North America went extinct do
you think that the 25% surviving came
through completely unscathed no it
simply means that there's a threshold
above which a species is viable it can
survive there's there and in below which
you know there may have been survivors
but there just weren't enough of them
they were too widely scattered serious
habitat loss which would have diminished
food supply and they just died out but
either directly or indirectly as a
result of these catastrophic
environmental changes that accompanied
the ending of the Ice Age humans had to
have been affected by this and all of
the myths and the stories would totally
concur with that idea you know that that
there were humans and they're all
consistent with this one detailed that
there were some humans that had
foreknowledge
and so they built arks Deucalion built
an ark just like Noah did looting a
piston built an ark disatrous built an
ark manu built an ark were these stories
coming from you know are they just
completely concerned up independently of
one another and that detail is just
thrown in or is there some kind of a
reality behind this that there were
people who had foreknowledge well if
there were people that had foreknowledge
it suggested suggests to me that there
were two groups of survivors those who
survived because they intentionally
planned to survive they had
foreknowledge they took steps to secure
their survival in Freemasonry there was
the account of of Lamech or the account
of Enoch there's variants of on it but
Enoch the story of Enoch in in in
Masonic tradition says that Enoch had
you know he was in the into the
patriarchs before Noah had this
foreknowledge that the world was going
to be destroyed either by fire or flood
so he created this underground vault it
was deep underground and it was
preserved within nine layers of stone it
was nine layered vault and you only
unless you had the key to accessing to
how to access the
vault which was now like a time capsule
that preserved the science and the
knowledge and the wisdom of the pre
diluvian world or pre-flood world he
then set up two pillars a pillar of
brass and a pillar of marble the pillar
of brass designed to withstand the
effects of the Cataclysm the watery
destruction the pillar of marble if I'm
remembering it right was to withstand
the the destruction by fire so there
were these two pillars that basically
informed any survivors that there was
this nine chambered underground vault
that contained the secrets of the
previous world age that is what's coming
to a pass and that's an intrinsic part
of Masonic tradition in fact the whole
Masonic symbolism is based around that
idea and and it has parallels throughout
other traditions as well well what I'm
getting at here is if if there was some
people who had foreknowledge of it and
took steps to survive they were the ones
who preserve the knowledge of the pre
the the previous the antediluvian World
Order the other survivors just survived
by the luck of the draw like that tree
standing there right they just happened
to be in the right place at the right
time they survived but now they are
going to be the ones who are going to be
wholly preoccupied simply with the task
of surviving finding enough food to eat
and shelter because clearly the
planetary environment was going through
all kinds of changes whereas the other
group had taken actual steps to survive
and preserve knowledge now when we look
at the beginning of recorded history
4000 to 5000 years ago we're basically
halfway back through the Holocene right
okay let's for purposes of conjecture
assume that at the end of the Holocene
human population crashed right well if
you want to build a pyramid or a great
temple you've got to have a labor force
right well if you've got scattered bands
of survivors you basically aren't going
to be able to accomplish that now let's
assume that you've got two groups of
humanity one that's sitting there with
all of this knowledge at their disposal
just like imagine
if our modern society was wiped off the
face of the earth but somebody somewhere
in some deep cave underground was able
to preserve our knowledge of physics and
chemistry and in the various Sciences
well obviously in order to run this
computer that we're running here to do
this broadcast requires an intact huge
intact infrastructure right well we
could know how to build a computer we
could know how to do how to broadcast
but if we don't have the infrastructure
we're just sitting on information right
well let's assume that you have a group
that survived right and they've got
they're the custodians of this body of
knowledge right now it takes 3,000 4,000
5,000 years for the human population to
reconstitute itself and now you've got a
labor force and let's suppose that
there's going to be another Cataclysm
impending you know such as the one that
perhaps caused the the Noah's Flood
which you know there's evidence now that
around 5,000 years ago there was an
asteroid impact into the Indian Ocean
right that plunged through 2 miles of
ocean water and blasted a 12 mile wide
hole on the floor of the Indian Ocean
and what year was this this would have
been about 5000 years ago now how much
of an impact would that have had oh it
would have created tsunamis well on the
island of Madagascar on the southern
island of Madagascar and it should be in
this in this program that we've got open
right here Jamie if you go to slide
number yeah go to slide number 111 it's
so ironic that today our focus is closer
and closer to the cloud closer and
closer to chips to solid-state hard
drives all these different things that
are just not gonna last right no paper
no but no-one's carving anything in
stone you know all the knowledge that we
have is like how much of what what
everybody has is on hard drives I mean
how much of what everybody has is in the
cloud on a you know a server somewhere
yeah and who the fuck is going to be
able to figure out
how to read that shit a thousand years
from now yeah just lightning happen to
us
yeah just like we're trying to figure
out how to read a Gyptian hi laughs okay
look at look at slide number hundred
eleven now I wish I had my pointer here
go to the next slide so you can see we
okay right there you see you see those
Wiggly things it's like dragon scales
yeah what that is is it's water ocean
water that washed on land and washed up
and you see it kind of comes to a point
and then it washed back out this is this
is a tsunami deposit and those features
that you're looking at they kind of look
like this
they're called Chevron's right that's
what happens when the water washes in
makes deposits of giant ripples and then
washes back out what kind of time frame
are you talking about when this happens
I want this to do that
Oh hours so that all happened in hours
in hours yeah I mean you could still see
it today oh yeah go to the next slide
Jaime we're getting a closer up look
here now you see how see how they're
shaped almost V like mm-hmm
that's the Chevron like a sergeant
stripe almost right okay go to the next
slide okay here's a cross section of one
of those v-shaped Hills it's 600 feet
and Heights wow that's incredible now
what so what you're seeing in the back
then up one more Jaime so those images
right there what we're seeing there it
looks like the effects of a river or
water or something it is water yeah but
then when you go back you see it from
the ground it looks like hills yeah 600
feet high so you're talking about a
massive amount of water we're talking
about a tsunami who's minimum run-up
height is the height the thickness of
these hills 600 feet minimum minimum
minimum and that's of course massive
amount of weight and devastation and
this was all five thousand years ago
yeah go to the next slide Jaime
yeah there's Madagascar location of the
Chevron's on the southern edge of
Madagascar let's see go to slides up and
over on the other side
at the same age if we look at the
southwestern coast of Australia I think
the next slide we'll get a closer in
view
there we go you see that splooge mm-hmm
that's that's the technical scientific
term is it really blue JH no I just made
that you bet you see they see the stuff
that's been washed over you can see it
it's very clear there okay that's the
other side of the ocean so the other
side of the ocean directly opposite of
where this thing impacted yeah goes
against massive impact in the middle
yeah
ancient crash epic wood let's go back to
that slide where from the where it says
ancient crash epic wave next slide keep
going right there right there
can we read that yeah the southern end
of Madagascar live for enormous
wedge-shaped deposits called Chevron's
that are composed of material from the
ocean floor each covers twice the area
of Manhattan with sediment as deep as
the Chrysler Building is high on close
inspection the Chevron deposits contain
deep ocean micro fossils that are fused
with medley of metals typically formed
by cosmic impacts holy shit yeah yeah
holy shit and so that if that happened
four thousand eight hundred years ago
mm-hmm
what kind of an impact would that have
had on human civilization oh well it was
pretty much would have wiped out
anything adjacent to the Indian Ocean
anything close to it but what about on
the other side of the planet I mean
there'd have to be some massive effects
oh there would be most likely what we
would see on the other side of the
planet is extreme weather events
hurricanes torrential rain falls things
like that when kill a huge amount of
people worldwide could kill a human
mount of people worldwide yes Wow and so
that is probably the most recent one
that's probably the most recent ah and
no record of it because people really
didn't have many records well I think
the record of it is probably when we see
these stories like Noah's Flood and the
rest so that's probably about this one
so it's not even about the Holocene one
it's about one 5,000 years after the
house
yes see that's what we're beginning to
realize now is that these events have
happened with a much greater degree of
frequency than anybody had imagined
well congratulations you freak me the
fuck out I just want to say you know you
had an objective and you pulled it off
five stars a plus freaked out wow this
is this has been an intense three hours
it just flew by three hours yeah we just
did three hours Wow it's over yeah
then amazing yeah we got to do this
again I bet you could talk for another
16 hours yeah I mean we barely scratched
the surface here oh please let's do it
again
let's take a couple months off regroup
and come back in again oh I'd love to do
some more please thank you very much for
doing this I really really appreciate it
is incredibly enjoyable incredibly
enlightening for me I really really
appreciate it I knew who's going to be
like this just the brief conversation
that we had a chance to have in Atlanta
you know many years ago I've been
looking forward to talking to you again
thank you very much for doing this oh
it's been awesome I really really have
enjoyed if people want to research more
of your work read more of your stuff
where can they go what can they or can
they find go to sacred geometry
international.com and there are links
there I've got another website that it's
linked from there so I can sacred
geometry international I deal with a
bunch of different stuff not directly
connected necessarily with what we're
talking about here but there will be
links to another website that I've got
where I'm really exploring like the
catastrophic stuff or I've got lots of
images of things yeah because I've done
lots and lots of field exploration they
have thousands of images of just awesome
stuff does the sacred geometry have
anything to do with this stuff or is
that a totally different sacred geometry
put it this way as we've inherited this
corpus of ancient knowledge sacred
geometry is one of the keys for
deciphering these ancient traditions
because all of these ancient temple
structures which are the textbooks in
stone if you will have several
components in in common astronomical and
geometrical being the two predominant
and if you understand the geometry you
realize the geometry is like a universal
code
by where whereby you can preserve
certain types of information because
geometry is universal doesn't matter
what your spoken language is the
principles of geometry are what they are
you know the relationship of a of a
radius to a circle is the same and it
doesn't matter what culture you come
from you see
and so geometry is a critical means of
deciphering the the knowledge that and I
think that the that the predominant way
of preserving ancient knowledge is in
the temple structures and they have to
be looked at as textbooks in stone and
once we begin to realize that then we
can go it's like when you go to Egypt
it's not just the hieroglyphs that's a
part of it but it's also the geometry
and the astronomy that's encoded there
and we can see the same astronomy at
work whether we're looking in Egypt
whether in geometry or whether we're
looking at megalithic structures in
ancient England or whether we're looking
at mega monumental earthworks up in the
Ohio Valley or we're looking at the the
mine you've been to Chichen itz right
okay that whole complex there is laid
out according to principles of sacred
geometry and astronomy and it's exactly
the same principles underlying that as
we find in Egypt that will be our next
conversation so I'd be a great combo I
can't wait I can't wait thank you so
much really appreciate it Randall
Carlson ladies and gentlemen you can
follow him on Twitter it's sacred geo
int for sacred geometry International
mm-hmm so yeah so sacred geo int on on
Twitter and sacred geometry
international.com mm-hmm is the website
thank you so much man really amazing and
I can't wait to talk to you again I'm
gonna start going over your material on
your website and and gear up too for our
next conversation man just amazing
amazing stuff thanks to our sponsors
thanks to on it com go to o n n I T use
the code word Rogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements and thanks also to
naturebox
the official snack provider of
during experience go to nature box.com
/r ogen to save 50% off your first box
that's nature box.com or slash rug and
we'll be back tomorrow with dr. Rhonda
Patrick returns and until then go fuck
yourselves how about that I don't mean
it I don't mean it I love you big kiss
see you soon
[Music]
[Laughter]